the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the race for the sink field cup is
heating up here in st louis it's been
neck and neck so far but after charging
forward with his second consecutive
victory maxine bashir lagrav left his
opponents in the dust to claim the first
sole lead of the event three chasers are
hot on his heels can they close the gap
or will the frenchman pull away from the
pack round eight of heart-stopping
clashes coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to saint
louis in the 2021 sink field cup we're
in the control room where all the magic
happens as we catch all the tension on
the players faces as they try to win it
all we've got wesley soul who knows that
he needs to keep pace with maxine
vashila grav if he's going to win it all
but also other chasers as well in
fabiano caruana and lanier dominguez
well we're going to jump to the action
right now with our super team of
alejandro and yasser
the beautiful city of st louis is
hosting its marquee tournament it's time
to finish off the sinkfield cup as we
only have two games remaining here in
the central west end to bring you all of
the action for the final leg of the 2021
grand chess tour i'm alejandra ramirez
here with grand master yasser sarawan
hello everyone hi alejandro pleasure as
always to call all the action with you
and maurice the pleasure has been ours
what a tournament these players have
given us fantastic full of decisive
games chases
tough events you name it we've had it
and more stories to come hello everyone
thank you for sharing your day with us
as we go into the penultimate round the
first half is amazing was amazing and
the second half is trying to duplicate
all of the great fun that we were having
in the first half we have a
marvelous finish in store epic i would
even say alejandro do the honors and
tell us who's leading the tournament
it's maxine vasher lagravdo number one
player from france he has five points
out of seven but take a look at those
people chasing him it's the olympic team
of the united states of america fabiano
carrano wesley so and linear dominguez
all have only half a point less than mvl
and they're gonna be hungry to get the
sinkfield cup for themselves fifty
percent we have richard report jeffrey
shang shakuyama of samshanklin on three
points peter spiller found his first
victory and now it sits at two and a
half points meanwhile luckless dario
spirits with one and a half points out
of seven and our format it's a ten
player round robin only two rounds
remaining and it's a classical event
that means 90 minutes for the first 40
moves 30 minutes at it when you reach
move 40 a 30 second increment from move
one and absolutely no draw offers in
this tournament you have to either find
a repetition or vacuum the board to
obtain that half a point and speaking of
half point traditional scoring system
one point for a win half for a draw zero
for a loss
and three hundred and twenty five
thousand dollar prize fund makes it the
most lucrative prize fund in the world
for tournament of this format and a
remaining schedule and may not be much
but they are crucial and crucial indeed
two rounds remaining here at the
sinkfield cup one round today and one
round tomorrow at the same exact time
3pm central if you we need a playoff for
the grand chess tour that will happen on
the 27th but we do not see that as a
possibility remember there's a tie for
the same field we do not do that on
playoffs exactly but what is the road
ahead for all of these players at the
very top well for that we have our
favorite grand master maurice ashley
well thanks alejandro the penultimate
round
for top players is the real money round
you don't want to go into the last round
desperate to score points you want to
get it done with a little bit of cushion
on your hands and we have four players
who are thinking very much about what
they need in this round so that they can
be prepared for the finish line first we
have maxine vashila grav at the top a
half a point ahead of fabiano caruana
wesley so and lanier dominguez look at
richard rapport though because although
full point behind the rest of the field
he could feature very much into who
takes the tour title and let's take a
look at the individual players fabiano
caruana with an amazing win yesterday
yesterday against
mamadirov he is now in a beautiful
position he gets round eight against
peters fiddler who did win yesterday but
hasn't had a great tournament so far and
against a very tough richard rapport
who's proven hard to beat even though he
has only a 50 score it's only lost one
game to get there
and lanier dominguez he played one of
the best tournaments one of the best
games in this tournament so far
in that brilliant victory against maxine
vashila grav he'll see if he can get
back some wins though because he's got a
lot of draw so far he'll be playing
against sam shanklin and then look at
that huge last round match up against a
player who is tied with him in wesley so
and speaking of wesley so the tour
leader
definitely does not want to lose today
as he faces off against the leader in
the singapore cup maxime vasciola grav
and then he has to play lanier dominguez
this is the toughest path of anyone
who's finishing out the tournament as a
leader or hoping to win it all we'll see
if wesley can handle his business here
it's going to be a tough day certainly
today because this man
maxim vashila grav has got five points
and he knows if he wants to win the tour
he's got to take wesley down this is a
big time game that they play today maybe
the biggest tournament
biggest game of the tournament as far as
the tour is concerned and you see max
seem there
ready and waiting and his road is clear
very simple the math
down to the decimal point we've
calculated it he needs to get at least
6.4 gct points more than wesley to
overtake him that means he wins the
tournament wesley needs to come in fifth
or lower that's pretty precise and
there's some scenarios that bear that
out and of course wesley knows as well
that with maxime chasing him he cannot
end up in fifth place it's that simple
fifth place and he's dead and why now
does richard feature in because if
wesley wins today and richard rapport
does not either draw or lose then he
will not fall to fifth will wesley and
he's guaranteed the tour title a win and
a draw or a loss by richard that's it
it's over tomorrow becomes irrelevant
but there are other scenarios wesley
could lose today but if he defeats
lanier tomorrow then he still wins the
title because lanier will not relegate
him to fifth place because wesley will
at least catch him with a win so he's
got those two things in mind
more likely at this level is is to end
up in a draw if he draws both today and
tomorrow he's again guaranteed to win
the tour once more if richard doesn't
win both his games that's going to be
hard richard plays fabian the last round
and fabi will be hunting him down so
wesley knows he's in a good situation
but if all else fails he also knows that
he could lose both games and still
somehow with a little bit of luck and uh
his lucky charm in his pocket thrown in
maybe it's his lucky cat he's got nearby
he could still win the tournament i
don't think he's looking at that
scenario at all please
but wesley so looks like he's in the
driver's seat right now guys lots of
scenarios where he wins but it starts
with him not losing today that's going
to be a huge result and a huge game as
maxine will be hunting him down thank
you maurice it feels like a
scriptwriter's dream as these matchups
are so
important um alejandro let's take a look
at not just today's round but we're
going to sneak ahead for tomorrow as
well but start with pairings for round
eight we got some of those key match-ups
for you by sherlock graf versus wesley
so fabiano carano versus svidler but
let's round off the table we have
jeffrey shank versus shakuyama dyarov
certainly an important one also for the
gct's tour maybe not for the first place
but also for third as fabio cavanaugh
and madero for fighting it out for that
one right speaking of other if other
richer report being an important result
today for the gct standings he's playing
with black against a weekend darius
wiertz absolutely and for fabby fabio he
could win he could win the sinkfield cup
that's a big one for him i know that
he's hungry for it he is white against
the player that just got out of a win
but he hasn't had a good tournament
exactly lanier dominguez also with a win
over sam shanklin he's fighting for
first and now our peak ahead for
tomorrow let's just see what round nine
will bring us we're going to be
finishing off the tournament with
shakuryar mamadarov against bashir
lagrave peter zwiddler against jeffrey
shong richard rapport against fabiano
caruana what a way to finish this event
sam shanklin versus darius schwartz and
wesley so against linear dominguez
that's going to be the key matchup of
the day no questions asked boy wesley
has got an
incredibly hard row
road ahead of him as he will be facing
mvl the tournament leader with the black
pieces but if i were in his shoes i know
i want the win of the prestige of the
sinfel cup but i want the title of grand
chess tour so i'm thinking if i can just
draw today
i will have
virtually sewn things up oh you're about
to see wesley go full defensive mode and
a berlin i guarantee
95 chance after
mvl defeated jeffrey zhang just two
rounds ago in the berlin ending
i mean we can almost guarantee that mvl
is going to go for that ending but in
truth
jeffrey's position was fine before he
made that critical blunder actually
maurice was saying that he was even
starting to think about getting the
initiative with the black pieces in that
position and we do have the brilliant no
surprise there no d3 by mvl i think d3
is played almost automatically by most
grandmasters nowadays but mvl sticks to
his guns he's extremely stubborn and
he's going straight into that end hold
on hold on hold on
hold on wait a minute okay leslie hasn't
moved that is true wesley's sitting
there thinking you actually want to go
into
that end game which i know very well
and we all know is often a draw at the
highest level
also after the fact did
mvo get up from the board it's
like on move three is that true because
i i he did get up from the board he's
back i mean
and there goes you know and he only
moved when he came back it's it's kind
of interesting because it's the same you
really want to play
exactly
exactly see i didn't think he'd be going
down for that position but let's see
what his plan is for our advantage
coming out of this position he must have
something well prepared i don't think
we've ever been that excited for a
rookie one i know i mean everybody we
were holding our breath there for just
that half half second yeah i just
couldn't imagine the
end game but this one looks even less so
than
the berlin ending we have seen so many
draws coming out of this specific line
of play
that is it possible that mci has decided
to back away from winning the tour and
just making it no if he wanted to make a
draw he had
versions of the berlin end game in which
he could have just said that's it that's
it i'm shutting it down right we're
making we're playing 25 moves of theory
if you remember that we make a draw if
you don't you lose exactly i think he
would have gone for something like that
he might have an idea he might just try
to play a position with zero risk
there we go i just like to turn our
attention to the game of fabi versus
peter svidler for a moment because this
was a joko piano and a rather different
uh one and one that wesley so really is
uh his
his
what what just happened there players
just got up right
like two players just got up
at the same time it was kind of busy
that was weird yeah that was really
weird i was just in the middle of saying
uh in the game between a fabi and peter
svidler a joko piano everybody's
favorite today c2 c3 knight f6 everybody
has been playing d3 however one wesley
sow has been looking at d4 takes e5 and
this is another
very long-winded variation of the joco
piano
that is also at the highest level really
uh getting tested as well it's tested
everywhere but i haven't found too much
success with the white pieces at the top
level actually black
no wesley so didn't wesley win with
white in one of those recent magnus
carlson
tour but when you're a wesley you win
every position
good point
uh it's supposed to be
still interesting but black has its own
resources and the thing about this
particular version of the duco piano not
really a joker piano anymore right is
that black gets his own chances i've
seen black win from this positions i've
seen black get smashed from these
positions so it's a little bit riskier i
would say than the normal traditional
joco piano lines that are so much slower
exactly and we see bishop e3
re-enforcing this pawn on d4 developing
frankly
yeah right develop
defend your weaknesses ha ha
bishop g4
pinning the knight would be one
uh counter
also i'm used to seeing f7 f6 trying to
break up the team in the center as a
source of counter play let's continue
just looking around
at the other games whoa this is
developing very slowly as derek is
playing
a
london system against
richard again richard figured
figured
prominently in the discussion that
maurice was having and it's remarkable
that a player
a tour player at that
uh who's at 50 could have such a big
impact
on the grand chess tour itself and it's
all about richard's positioning of the
tournament because wesley needs to get a
certain amount of gct points to
guarantee his position remember if he
ties wesley and maxine who takes the
whole event exactly that might not be
enough just catching up with uh wesley
and
mvl for a moment when we have left it
we've seen this
and
d4 also uh knight i i remember here at a
sinkhole cup uh in a game between
ikaru nakamura and i want to say magnus
carlsen they essayed a lengthy
theoretical discussion that went like
this and you don't even have to go that
far behind if bishop d6 rookie one
knight f6 was the game schwerzmadyarov
earlier in this tournament where mahmud
was arguably arguably a little bit worse
than that in that game okay but we have
a completely different approach here
with d2d4 now the question is after d7
d5
how on earth are you supposed to follow
up and say hey i've got some great
advantage uh the reason i say this is
because as a french defense player and i
used to hate it when my opponents would
play the exchange french because i just
felt that my winning chances as black
went way
somebody somebody actually apologized to
me for playing the exchange franchise
against me were they trying to get a
norm they were trying to get a norm and
they said i'm sorry i wanted to play
against you but it's a norm and they got
their draw which is a little frustrated
exactly yeah okay but this is one of
those french exchange franchises with a
pair of knights off as well no this in
the exchange french
i used the exchange french to get my gm
norm that's white uh by
beating alexander chavalov i believe it
was 22 moves with the white pieces i
have to say there's somebody that you
want to play
you pick the perfect opponent but you
want to neutralize that guy don't don't
don't give him anything to get excited
i was playing for the victory thank you
when i played the exchange fringe i
played with c4 and move after the
exchange uh move four
uh
yeah
three four yeah yes i played with c4
knight c3 bishop d3 and played a reverse
tarish and there's some nuances in there
okay so no i did not play it for a draw
and i did not play because shabba scared
the heck out of me uh and i wasn't even
a gm yet like i said i beat him both
times as i am when i played him later he
knew exactly who he was facing often
shabo washaba
he caught me
a few on the chin and afterwards but he
didn't know the youngin was coming with
some swings and i did catch him out
there in one of my favorite games in the
exchange french
beat him in style wonderful i just want
to say that there's a very different
twist that mvl has played in his game
with wesley
an intriguing move at least i find it
very intriguing
b2b3 it's not very subtle
i mean we're used to seeing this bishop
coming out here we're used to seeing
bishop coming to d3 and queenie coming
into f3 and white achieving nada zero
nothing but b2 b3 as you were about to
say
does have a clear purpose i want to
snare this rook on
f8 with a move bishop a3 um do we
believe it i think
you are it is a real threat because of
course the the knight coming to d6 which
is the only way to save that rook would
interfere with the queen defending the
pawn on d5 right it
so
two thoughts came immediately to my mind
the first was bishop e6 right i love
development who does it bishop e6 bishop
a3
knight
d um six the thing that maybe
gave me some pause was the move knight
b5 and we see c6 even then bishop e7
exactly you're still you're still
keeping the um but c6 is very large you
could find fabi watching there
what's happening
what is this about and queen after he's
banging down moves
bishop a3 bishop knight d6 and that's a
pawn sacrifice on the d4 square this guy
has prepared some nasties for this game
uh you can't touch that pawn i don't
think because of i was going to say
no rook do you want anything d1 looks
and i think knight takes d5 will come
well i wanted to get right back
and
is it is it real or what how do you
defend the knight the knight is
definitely under attack queen b4 is a
threat queen g3 not so much because
knight f5 gets away with a
tempo even then queen e5 might still be
quite dangerous yeah i see queen b4 is a
big threat yeah definitely i don't see
how to stop it
so the what what it's actually kind of
an immune i'm not used to seeing this
kind of thing it's very rare bishop
queen before now if you move your knight
you think okay
no no no i'll just take the rook that's
an exchange that's an exchange so
um
yeah you can't i don't know when
these days when you see these top-level
grand masters coming out and just going
bang bang bang and i'm going to
sacrifice upon i find myself very
reluctant to want to expect that you
know you can't touch that there's no way
he's now under the gun what a weird line
to find but we always make this point
though
you might find the path to equality
players at this level they're not
looking for an advantage mm-hmm they're
just not
the engine says no advantage for you
black can save your saves with best
what they're looking for is a complex
enough position
where you can't solve the situation
easily right they you just go oh
this is what i do this is what i no
you're gonna sit you're gonna look
you're gonna say wait what is he
prepared if i take the pawn on d4 that
looks i'm gonna die in that line okay
what else should i do and you start
looking for your most natural moves and
he's got all the natural responses to
your natural boos and so you're stopped
you're thinking like wesley's right now
going oh boy okay
this guy played b3 bishop a3 he's
getting up on every move i'm playing the
moves he suspected would happen right
the heart starts to be a little bit
faster he's like calm it down calm it
down he's here to kill me but i'm wesley
so get that confidence back but don't
trip because his computer's saying this
natural move loses that one okay that
one's okay that one over there big edge
you know
so wesley
is gonna have to keep his composure in
this moment because queen of three
that's the kind of move wesley could be
there for 20 minutes right all right
let's let's think while it's wesley
stern it is our marquee matchup
absolutely so i'm going to develop so uh
prove your point bishop bishop issac i'm
developing
my most natural movements i i have two
moves in mind rook e8 getting out of the
pin moving my knight the only queen f4
i'm afraid of this queen f4 i have to
retreat the bishop because i want to
defend the knight on d6 exactly i don't
have time to move the knight whoops
that's an exchange can't do it bishop e7
and then bishop d3 now bishop d3 now
finally i can
ruin my knight can i play knight f5 i
wanted to ask knight e8 but knight f5
wow
i feel like there's a problem with the
putter on e6 if we can go down the line
bishop takes a3 bishop takes c6 pawn
takes c6 but tactically i was thinking
that at the end i have this bishop
bishop is very strong right right so uh
just going after the willy-nilly queen
g4 will be met by bishop b2 what you
said so i might
be forced to
to reign in my horns
e5 is tough queen f6 is also tough but i
like e5 yeah that that sort of like
messes me up from at that perspective so
maybe
well i i don't know i've i've played a
lot of french's and i'm i'm not
convinced that this pawn is a real
weakness because this looks fine for
black i've got enough play so knight f5
looks playable
uh if i had done it the other way just
playing i don't know simple chess bishop
takes knight takes not that i'm a
huge fan of this but i do see
some potential maybe
knight g6
by the way how do these two specifically
match up against one another alejandro
it's a surprising amount of victories
for fbl a whitewash 4-0 in favor of the
french player wesley has never defeated
mvl in classical trust but they have
split the point many times i would have
lost a very big wager on that uh wesley
so so
a
solid player
four losses and no wins zero wins
who does that to wesley maxine bashar
allah graph maximum sure that asked and
answered um the other move i wanted to
ask you about is when we got to this
position with queen f4 bishop e7 and i
agree with you that bishop d3 is is a
likely way of going i wasn't a big fan
of putting my knight on f5 okay i was
kind of a i was more thinking that you
know i put my knight on f6
and you know life is pretty good
actually uh i'll defend my king site so
is there something better than bishop e
e7 and bishop f5
not really too sure not really seeing it
at least right so if we go if we do go
down this line and and black manages
through
just to trade off a lot of pieces
um he'll be doing well by the way bishop
f5 immediately kind of
runs into a showstopper queen f6 so
this knight on c3 needs a better
yeah and this is why the main lines
usually run with the quick knight e2
knight g3 right as opposed to b3
but that's the question right bishop e6
do we have a better idea after bishop e6
uh by all means please uh
if you see one uh jump right in
maybe 92 right away
yeah 92 knight f4 you're trying to hit
that bishop i'm not exactly convinced
about what i'm doing
um
maybe getting out of this pin at last
and
knight shows up and i'm not even sure if
you can take on d4 that's at this point
it starts to get started it starts to be
a yummy yeah yeah
yummy there on the right you have to
defend that phone at some point exactly
i was thinking something like this too
by the way because now that this
diagonal gets cleared one of the moves
that i really wanted to try to
take advantage of the bishop on a3 was
maybe queen a5 i mean i'm going to try
to embarrass uh the bishop on a3 with
such a move so i'm starting to think
black's better yeah i queen coming to a5
it doesn't feel like the most effective
development but we'll leave we'll we'll
we'll leave it up to wesley to see how
he's going to solve at this issue let's
just again i wanted to check in with our
final game lanier versus
sam shanklin you know i always loved it
i really i mean to say this in in in a
very respectful way when two
great theoreticians did battle i mean
it's almost like a correspondence game
you know it it drew my attention and i
do think uh in those terms that lanier
and sam shanklin
really really work hard on their games
and they come as well prepared
as just about anybody on tour
what
do we call this variation with knight f3
i don't think it has a name it's just
the knight f3 bishop b3 line as opposed
to knight b3 line yeah i don't think it
actually has any name it's not the
english attack because you're not going
to be playing f3 obviously your knights
in the way it's extremely positional
compared to knight b3 knight b3 you put
the knight on the queen side it's a bit
offside but it does allow you to go f3
eg4 g5 eight
tiger right you get them right but with
the knight on f3
yeah things change
and now it becomes more of a positional
struggle right over the dd5
and after knight f3 bishop e7 and bishop
c4 you can imagine that
belongs with the
idea of the position to take advantage
of the d5 square
there's many ways to play this for black
many people are playing queen c7 a lot
of people are actually playing queen c7
before bishop e7 so that you don't have
the bishop c4 move uh-huh taking away
one of white's options again as you
pardon me not not bishop e7 and that's
like queens e7 stopping bishop c4 and
then the fight takes a different path i
mean soon there's many ways to play this
for wide you can go a4 you can go knight
d2 to still insist with the move bishop
c4 i really want to make my bishop come
to c4 tons of ideas in this position but
bishop b7 is completely fine bishop c4
knight c6 is one of the main lines
sometimes the knight goes to d7
sometimes the knight goes to c6
right this knight on b8 sometimes goes
to d7 sometimes it goes to c6 it has
gone to c6 in fact and is that
based on the idea of maybe knight
uh a5 to hunt down this bishop most of
the time that i've seen this position
the
way that you get rid of the light square
bishop is just by putting your own
bishop on bishop on e6 you have to make
sure that you don't get hit by knight g5
so you have to time it appropriately so
and if for argument's sake i just make a
move like this you go bishop e6 and
that's the
prescribed way if you will of
neutralizing the bishop on c4 one of
many but it depends on where every piece
is being placed you want to see how much
time white is investing into the d5
square yeah
before you decide all right i need to
ruin my structure to get rid of this
bishop got you it almost feels like uh
it's spanish
yeah it's like yeah doesn't it it really
has the resemblance of an anti-martial
spanish in which you go bishop e6 at
some point you trade off the bishop you
lose the pawn structure but you get
control over the d5 square that you
weakened right 20 moves ago and this by
the way what alejandro and i just did is
very very very typical of grand masters
what we do is we take ideas from other
openings and we make a comparison to
this specific thing and they go oh yeah
and the the anti-marshall we get this
and now we have that
uh and then we weighed the scales it's
it's
it's funny how we make those
associations and maurice we haven't come
to you my man what have you
uh oh yeah you've been focused on our
marquee matchup i've been digging a
diggy trying to figure out what maxine
might have looked at what wesley
might try to respond with
and i just found a line that you guys
are going to love
this line is just so sweet
here's the line knight to f5 is possible
wow absolutely get out of i mean seeing
this for the first time would be
extremely risky of him to actually play
this way
but it is a sacrifice that could change
the tenor of the game and say you came
with prep i'm going to counter with this
idea that creates some chaos on the
board and here we go bishop takes on f6
on f8 knight takes on d4 tempo all right
tempo you're ready to take the bishop
back on f8 you'll have an exchange
you'll have given up an exchange but you
have a pawn and a bishop beautiful dark
square bishop for that exchange you
could see the power of the bishop down
the line coming to f5 too yeah and the
bishop in the game
position's on fire black's doing well
right yeah i like this you like it i
like it yeah
how do you like that get out of here
queen takes f6 yeah
he's got a rook in his hand he gave him
a pawn all right but now he's got a
bishop in his hand don't be touching
that queen with your queen to keep the
pawn structure because you can resign
the game is over wow
it's just done you there's nothing to do
about bishop e7 bishop d7 drops a rook
and there's just nothing to do the
bishop is coming back out and you lose
so that's that that variation cannot be
played gf
yeah so instead uh let me go back here
after queen f6 gf6 bishop to e7 and as
you mentioned
nes bentanov the threat of taking on f6
attacking the knight bringing the rook
into the game a possible knight e4 to
take on f6 as well and it's a rook and
bishop for queen and pawn but great
dynamic compensation
if he had gone this route wow wesley did
not go this route and fought wesley
decided to play very traditionally yes
let's not do anything crazy in this
position vision b6 queen f4 bishop e7
and bishop to d3 a line that we looked
at we thought knight at five had some
real chances for black but
guess who's moving instantly
one guy
he's saying hey i know exactly what's
going on i'm not gonna stop slow down
you need to find all the moves because i
am a position or positions in mind where
i think i have chances for you to mess
up and maybe lose the game
wow wow i would have noticed
that
yeah none of that line by the way uh by
the way just in that exchange sacrifice
if you don't mind me bring if you don't
mind bringing it up for me maurice i
wanted to say knight takes d4
queen moves just queen most queen g3 not
queen take queen takes f8 sign me up for
this exchange sacrifice i've got a
really powerful bishop
great pawn
if i get my bishop to f5 i'm going to
have a super super safe king
and what's not to like for western this
the whole diagonal looks fantastic he's
a pawn hanging at the moment knight f5
could bother your pieces
like whoa this looks really good really
good
[Laughter]
it's a move like that i got to tell you
guys the stories so we have
those playful who are really fastidious
about their scoresheets like peter laco
is one of them he makes his scoresheets
it's almost like a work of art uh
juan baionne a grandmaster from spain
another guy he's got all of these
multi-colored crayons as well
and he he
and you make a move like queen takes f6
and these guys have their pens in their
hands they're ready and then they just
stop
the pen remains frozen in there and
they're looking at your move it's like
what
clean up sex that would have been a
great move we didn't check in and i
apologize to jeffrey and shaq we didn't
check in on their game uh jeffrey white
a7a6 this is kind of made popular by
magnus yeah you know recently
uh a couple of weeks ago maybe three
weeks ago instead of the move a6
somebody told me that h6 here is
playable and there was some analysis
there what and i thought
come on get out of here right let's go
that's not that's not how chess works no
yeah then they showed me some analysis
and i couldn't refute it myself the
engine was saying it was kind of okay
prove that really everything is being
made playable nowadays
gross trust me if you're watching this
show you're not losing because of the
openings you can play anything you want
and you'll be okay
so we have a queens gambit bishop f4
variation with a quick c7 c5 this is all
more or less logical right and a6 is a
useful move right i'm not sure how
useful because i would have rather
broken on d4 rather than played a6 you
know but a6 sometimes you can tuck your
bishop away and you can kind of play for
d5 d4 uh the players are looks like a
rather theoretical uh situation for me
at least something very similar even if
it's not exactly theoretical what you
were telling us before you compare and
contrast you've seen this structure a
million times you know where the bishop
belongs you know where the rooks belong
you know where the ideas are it doesn't
have to be a specific position it's more
important to know the ideas of your
variations and certainly both players
here well aware one of my favorite books
ideas behind the opening by reuben fine
it was a very very old book but it
taught me to think not in terms of just
memorizing
the moves i go here my opponent goes
there i go there my opponent goes there
but the ideas behind the openings what
you're trying to achieve by the way big
shout out to our audience not only thank
you for joining us but thank you for
participating uh you have been sending
us tweets throughout these broadcasts
and they've kept us on our toes and very
very entertaining questions alejandro
and join our conversation it's hashtag
sing field cup on twitter our
international master kossie kavutski is
looking at all those tweets replying to
many of them
but the best come up here question 4
maurice ashley yasser and alejandro in
your opinion is the old-fashioned stance
that blitz and bullet games damage a
player's quality in classical chess
entirely anachronistic or does it
deserve some merit hashtag sing kill cup
[Music]
where are you leaving i
have recently worked with
the best second best player in the world
fabiano caruana and we thought that
blitz was absolutely mandatory that you
do not become a good chess player
anymore if you can't blitz you need to
practice your openings you need to be
able to think properly in quicktime
controls you need to
react properly when your own game goes
down to seconds and it just freshens up
your mind there is nothing that you can
study in chess that will prepare you as
much as a real battle so
blitz i think is an absolute must if you
want to become a top player if you want
to improve chess i think blitz is also
an absolute must in moderation of course
we're not telling you to go binge you
know 12 hours of chest.com or whatever
it's certainly part of an import of our
routine bullet chest on the other hand
no calories there you know empty
calories there
you're not doing anything with bullet
it's fun it's exciting i like playing it
myself you know have a cup of wine or a
beer play some bullet but it's not going
to improve your chest at all is it going
to damage it though
maurice jump in on this one
uh i agree with everything you just said
there's almost nothing to add
i'll add anyway because you know right
right right right right right bullet
bullet is pure empty calories like just
it's you're losing you're making people
flag the whole point is to flag so quick
exchanges you have no moment to stop and
think about is this exchange forced uh
fantastic or fantastic you know
or fabulous you have none of that you're
you know or or f'ed up you know i mean
like the last f like all that you
you don't do you just go ah
you're down hey i won that one and so
bullet is out blitz however you do have
some time to consider and think
and
there's a lot that's instinctive and
also you could train for openings with
with blitz you can say this is the most
effective form of blitz to say all right
what we're going to do is we're going to
play this line of the night off and
we're going to do it both sides over and
over again and let's train with it and
that way you can get much more
familiarity as you're getting a lot of
games in in a particular opening so
thematic blitz to me is absolutely
wonderful training
in addition to the instinct stuff you
think this stuff you were talking about
alejandro and i think that the old
so-called old-fashioned guys whatever
that old-fashioned statement is so many
people like fischer tal
uh you name it kasparov all these were
great buff these guys were brilliant
blitz players brilliant bass players
yeah and they're natural like the board
again for situat not only situational
like you said alejandro where you will
get down on the clock and you need to be
somebody who feels confident in that
situation
but
again that practice of so many games and
allowing you to think quickly on your
feet in case of trouble that's great
training
but you know they're the people who only
play blitz and bullet who say that's
justification
uh or at least not bullet let's say
blitz
maurice said it alejandro said it that
means i should be playing only blitz
that's what i should do all these blitz
i'm playing is good that's not what
we're saying that's not what we're
saying more classical
the better
i don't have much to say ad i think you
both
covered it really well only i have a
very firm conviction that carthage must
be sacked carthage yeah oh wrong speech
wrong sorry sorry sorry
i'll tell you the association later
we want to know now why it was a
roman senator he always began his
speeches with it's been my firm
conviction that carthage must be sacked
and then he would talk about whatever
he wanted but it was pretty funny anyway
um
what do you got for us maurice i'm
confused from what you just said so i
want to try to get my head back
i don't know if carthage is being sacked
here but
we do see that the two bishops have been
given up by caruana he took on c6
earlier and if this is his preparation
he's got peter thinking somewhat as i
say if this is preparation the guy is so
well prepared of course
but he's got peter thinking he's got 134
and 24 to peter's 111. that means he's
been instantly moving accumulating time
from the 130 he started with peter is
thinking why are we in this line uh let
me see up the guys got something figured
out there is an unbalanced pawn
structure on the queen side of the board
very unbalanced there's some unbalanced
imbalance here
but over here with this four against
three and the funny structure and the
bishop that doesn't look that great
bobby must have looked into this and
said i think i can do something with
this that's how you play these positions
i think i can do something i'm
the guy's got a little bit of discomfort
this bishop has no real future or life
let's see if i can shut that down but is
it enough i should add by the way the
knight on e5 as well doesn't look like
anyone's going to challenge it because
there's no knight
and there's no
presence from this dark square bishop
remember what we say when you play the
move bishop takes knight
bishop takes knight depending on which
bishop you use it's right here
right
everything is even distribution two
bishops two bishops night night but when
he plays the move bishop takes c6 and
his opponent plays back b takes c6 now
he takes and queen takes and now knight
to e5 he's giving away a light square
bishop that means he can not control the
light squares as well as black black has
this dark square bishop bishop five
queen a4 c5 castles he's given away his
light square bishop his opponent has a
light square bishop so white is weaker
on the light squares root b1 you're
never playing that move there's a bishop
just training down on the light squares
and he could try to do something but if
you you've given up your lights to a
bishop you're going to dominate on the
other caller because your opponent
cannot control at least you hope to your
your opponent can compete with this
piece but can't compete with that piece
that knight on e5 bobby is hoping that
the knight on e5 more than compensates
on the dark square control for what he's
given up on the light squares
thank you maurice absolutely
because richard rapport is figuring so
prominently in the road ahead that the
the the players have for victory i
thought i would just check in
and it was always a question i had for
those people who love to play the london
system what happens if the guy just
copies you and says your bishop on f4 is
really magnificent i'm going to put my
bishop on f5 and that's exactly what
richard did and after the move bishop d3
bishop g6 c4 bishop to d6 he said why
can't we be friends and you just play
bishop on f4 to
g3 or if you would prefer
trading off bishops i like that too
and
direct played the move bishop g5 and for
me this was always like oh man you just
lost a crucial tempo you went bishop f4
and you stuttered step your way to
bishop to g5 and i feel that black is
already equalized after this move it
maybe it's a very strong statement how
do you feel about that uh one uh
alejandro your student it's modern chess
it's moderate
actually this is this line it's
considered to be a good try for equality
but it doesn't equalize a hundred
percent it's one of those positions
where white plays without too much risk
okay you do have some chances of
ending up in a better position and it's
not
don't get me wrong it's not like a huge
advantage right right right you start
getting a bit more of a pleasant
position because you got in the move c4
and this is what the game is about you
got in the move c4 your bishop is
threatening the one on g6
so you
are asking in some ways
slightly unpleasant questions if i play
knight c3 and i'm threatening to take on
d5 how are you going to defend do you
really want to play a semi's love
structure so if i for example play as in
a queen's gambit decline kind of way
instead of having a bishop buried maybe
on the c8 square which would be more
normal normal i've got the bishop over
here on g6 and i'll play knight d7 and
say okay are you playing e4 are you
playing e4 but more pressingly if i take
on g6 and i start delaying castle
okay bishop takes g6 h takes g6 and
there's like we need to que e2 there's
also possibilities of queen b3 i'll get
into those later because because the
bishop is no longer on c8 the pawn on b7
is a slight weakness okay i can i can uh
understand that that queen b3 uh
hits the pawn but okay let's say you
play queenie too and the question this
is of course not a great movie and
you're not
you're not you're delaying you're
delaying castle very specific reason the
specific reason is simple if you castle
short i castle the other way and i kill
you first aha because you've got
something that you you can hook on with
h4 and h5 and suddenly my bishop on g5
looks really good it's well placed uh
but are you sure you killed me first oh
no i'm not sure this becomes very
double-edged right then you're wondering
why didn't i play my queen on c2 and
detail so the positions start becoming
important okay okay but this on the
other hand is a game that i say whoa
double edge
absolutely we've got kings on the
opposite flanks let's let's let's roll
yeah let the party get started and
that's not necessarily what's going to
happen but it just gives you an
indication of how if black so it's not a
dead dead game at all not at all it
could blow up it can blow up of course
the london not the most theoretical
variations and
richard's saying yes i do not want to
challenge you with c5 which is another
possibility of this position he did go
with
c7 a little bit more sedate a little bit
more normal okay we'll keep our eye on
this one as we'll jump back to maurice
in our marquee matchup with the
tournament leaders maurice yes you guys
are talking about the move knight to f5
by the way that was the engine's first
recommended move wesley played a move
that you may not come too quickly at
first
and
after some thought by the way he played
knight back
to e8 now we know the knight had been
back on eight or moved nine what's your
move yeah right earlier before so you
like this move 98
queen takes
bishop takes queen takes did occur we're
at this point right now and maxime for
the first time has stopped to think in
the position his actual trade was
somewhere he stopped for some reason he
had been running running running right
freeze frame let's take a look the
knight on e8 is not a great piece no but
there are multiple ways to attack this
position one way is h4 like just start
pretending there's something hanging out
on this side because h4h5 looks i mean
h4h5h6
looks like a dangerous way to proceed
the other way is what he played
right into the middle of the board on e5
right if it it's important to note any
and like that's a huge looking move
notice that the bishop on e6 being a
light square piece cannot compete
against this rook but i also want you to
take note of what would have happened in
the line after bishop to d3 if knight f5
now you guys have looked at some weak
pawn on e6 variations and assess that
this one would have allowed
this trait to be answered by knight
takes on e7 the point being that this
move can now be met by knight to g6
good or bad the move
was possible because this knight comes
here you've got to take this piece off
and hg6 and play this position solid
bishop against this knight which doesn't
seem like it's doing much right now so
this line is a line that he eliminated
by putting his knight back on e8 and
he's allowed this gorgeous looking rook
on e5
it looks like he's going to double it
looks like everybody is going one way
the weakest piece is this night on c3
however it needs to find a greener
pastures maybe e2 g3 and start hanging
out on this side wesley can feel a
little bit of pressure brewing
it's not so easy to solve completely
what's happening over here
clearly maxime came to play today and
he's refusing to stay at the board he's
trying to play quickly and with pressure
right i've seen these types of and i've
tell you i see
hikaru
neutralize white's position with moves
like queen f6 g6 knight g7 uh go ahead
and show us what if wesley played such a
move offering the queen trade could mvl
really build up anything well
there are a couple of questions do you
want to even allow the queen shade with
the move queen g3 right right or maybe
the move knight e2 and play this
position if you trade queens right and
allow this setup right right now what do
you do bishop
knight c7 knight c7 so nice e7
i guess you're you're going to be
putting your rook right right that's the
whole concept i've seen nikaru do this
kind of thing the engines get better for
white
and significantly better but the
variation that it's suggesting i don't
think is that serious it gives this line
and then it gives f3
bishop d7 and king to f2 i
i mean i personally wouldn't be that
impressed it's still saying
an edge for a while
i want to keep making moves its first
move
and here now the advantage has slipped
and it's it's saying slight enough
advantage for white nothing that
impressive gotcha i think this is
rolling towards that neutralization
you're talking about yeah i've just seen
again some really really good great
players hikaru magnus somehow they
neutrally personally i wouldn't play any
of these moves i mean against queen f6
i'd want to move my queen i mean right
it's even giving queen takes us a big
edge even bigger edge but what if we
move our queen back this is where i've
seen the guys play g6
knight g7
again this knight bothers me horribly
like where to put this piece
exactly i have to say
this games always look
pretty equal right but there was
actually a game that was burned into my
memory where i thought
wow absolutely nothing in this position
like absolutely nothing and it was this
type of exchange french structure yeah
nothing's happening it was actually rich
a report of the black pieces
richard rapport is playing against
ventala hari krishna in shenzhen of 2019
and i was there present at the
tournament
and the only advantage hare krishna was
had was pawn on h5 that was it buttered
h5 black didn't have as much space and
he rapport got crushed i mean crushed
crushed like from that tiny advantage i
didn't see how he fully equalized at any
point wow and he slowly got out played
he slowly got outplayed
and that end game that you guys were
showing at the end
i didn't think it was so equal it was
one of those end games that i'm starting
to feel
yes
you might draw it 90 of the time but
there will be percent of the time that i
actually press it and the nice thing i
like for mvl's prep is the tournament
situation he doesn't want to risk the
singfield cups
90 000
or i mean
all for the grand chess tour but he
still wants to keep options open of
beating wesley sending him down on those
grand chester points and taking the
entire thing for himself right this is a
perfect prep he gets some pressure no
risk never going to lose this position
up on time yeah what else do you want
from a position nope that's exactly
right i remember and i was the u.s
women's team captain in baku and it was
sort of like we've got these four
players and it's sort of like ladies
when you're white put pressure on your
opponents you know that's all we want it
was just and a big shout out to robert
hess their coach by the way who did just
yeoman's work um but that's exactly what
you want
pressure with white especially if it's
less risk yeah okay we'll keep an eye
and again maurice back to yourself as i
think you're pulling up the game that uh
that alejandro was citing well you know
my boy says again yeah you gotta get it
you gotta give it a look and this is
what you were talking about alejandro
the pawn on h5 uh
structure exactly the same as in the
game the stem game we're here now with
wesley uh let me see if i can pull get
some space for us there there make it
bigger all right so h5 later in the game
pieces were traded we'll jump a little
bit further rooks are off the board but
again the structure advantageous
structure and then even later we still
we get a position like this one
where
not much has changed
little advantage this bishop over this
night note that it's a dark square
bishop though that is true it's just
dark very important subtlety that it's a
dark square bishop so you can dominate
along the dark squares while your pawns
are dominating on the light squares and
here you play the move bishop to b6
and after bishop b6 knight b6 ab6
suddenly this pawn became an annoyance
as well and this is where
this breaks c4 wow wow that's very
visual as a move uh dc for
dc4bc dc4bc4
cd4 let's just go forward
and queen to d8 and just some hassling
that allowed him to get a position like
this one where the pawn was rolling down
the board hiding his king
a check another check and and see wait
what did i get this position c6
breakthrough this is what did it in the
game the c6 move was just too strong he
traded b7 and he tried to go down to
this end game but the king was safe and
it was all about the pawn queening so
that's this game that was a beautiful
thing right right i could understand why
yeah yeah i'm hard-wired i was like a
pun on h5 a darts for bishop and
suddenly i understand there's some
danger
that was very nicely done 55 moves that
took wesley sorry yeah wesley would not
be happy if it took
if he lost in that kind of fashion let's
get back
to this position with rookie five right
the difference here no dark square
bishop that's right to be
to be having even any potential
advantage
over a night
the peace distribution is similar
knight and bishop versus knight and
bishop so you haven't yet established
well what's my advantageous minor piece
right well you have the same structure
pretty much yeah but i don't have an
advantage in in the minors so
that little edge you're talking about
there could be some space but if a
mobile like queen of six happens
you know you might argue you're this
bishop is better than this one but
i'm not fearing this end game the same
way splitting hairs this is different
right i agree it's different but it's a
very bad bishop for black if you leave
that bishop on e6 when i go f3 g4 h4h5
my bishop participates on the king side
tickling h7
maybe maybe f5 c8 one day and a very
good day but yeah exactly right so i
agree equal but not fully equality yes
by the way talking about equal but not
fully equality i like to turn our
attention to the game of fabiano versus
peter svidler is like
the definition of equal but not equal
but not equal right because uh let's see
what happened when we have left it we
left it in this position
uh c5 takes d4 c3 takes d4 c5 says peter
let's go takes takes takes takes and we
are reached this position i'm
anticipating a move like queen b4 maybe
there's something to be argued for queen
b5 but you know these bishops have
opposite color and a lot of people just
stop and say okay bishop's pops of color
easy draw well it's all about the
vulnerability of the king
black's slightly more vulnerable if
white gets
and and he needs a few moves he needs to
post his bishop on d4 tickling this pawn
on g7 he needs to put his pawn on f3 so
there's no reciprocal i'm hitting g7
you're hitting g2 kind of thing and if
he can do those things while activating
his rooks
white will win easily now the question
is can he do that alejandro not so easy
to stop that
the thing i don't like about black's
position is the lack of plan okay it's
true that you're not really worse i mean
you have your bishop's not that bad
right you can park it in many other
places you can park it on c4 for example
but it could be anchored on the c4
square anchored on the g6 work yes it
doesn't lack squares right you're
probably not going to lose your pawn on
b6 i'm sure there's a tactical way of
defending it right
even bishop d3 b5 if you need it at some
point the real question is what's your
plan right because if white doesn't
trade heavy pieces any of them he really
doesn't want to trade any of them right
and starts pressuring you and starts
binding you to defending g7 and starts
binding you to defending the b-pawn
at some point your resources will be
stretched thin white will be attacking
all over the board you're not going to
be able to avoid the penetration of the
rooks one day either through the c file
or the e file
i'm not going to trade off for right
that way then then i agree we would
agree to withdraw but again
equal but not equal equal but not equal
you can imagine that black has enough
resources to beat back such an attack
you can hopefully trade more than one
pair of rooks you trade queens you'll
probably be okay but it's not easy to
force those trades so still some work to
be done by swiddler again one of those
positions in which white is playing with
the free advantage no risk whatsoever
pretty much what do you want at this
level of chess absolutely i liked a
question from our audience about how
blitz
and
whether it's great or
not so great let's let's take another
tweet alejandra let's see
how much does the reading of your
opponent
attitude time etc can influence one's
tactical choice let me read that again
how much does the reading of your
opponent okay so i think he means like
the expressions and how are you reacting
to your opponent's mannerisms during
the board and i would say at the amateur
level if i can take this one what an
incredible trap that is you see your
opponent suffering oh
and they just say oh my tactic must be
winning right actually when i was a kid
i have a kind of funny story please
my opponent set up a trap and i'm not
nine years old oh he gets up from the
board and in a place that's still very
visible from my board
he hits the wall like with his head like
i can't believe he's an idiot
i left my my piece hanging
so of course nine-year-old alejandro
sensing victory no i it was a very
obvious trap so i just avoided it
but he tried it was not bad not bad
maurice have you fallen for your
opponent's tales when maybe they weren't
towels at all no please
no no
brooklyn brooklyn brook brooklyn in the
building we don't we don't fall
that kind of trickery is not going to
work
we've seen enough of those hustles
before
uh no i'm trying to think of a good
example in
my own career i don't i do know
that i have tricked someone else
you know kind of shamefully
not your proudest moment
but you know it's one of those positions
where
uh you could stalemate with a a pawn
king
and
it's like a mad rook or something no
no it was
you you've also you've seen this trick
it actually was a sparrow of short match
where
kasparov could have possibly drawn with
this it's a stalemate trick where you
take a pawn with a rook and after rook
pass pawn when rook takes work your king
is stalemated
because yeah it's because
yeah there's a king pony i'm going to
set the position now okay i'm going to
let you answer i'm going to set the
position because
because i can give you the position but
the audience may not be able to
visualize it all i but but i'm going to
complete my story part two in a moment
okay so for me when i was starting yeah
at the class level i was very much
reacting to my opponent and and
especially if they were like nervously
looking at the clock i got nervous and
started looking at the clock as well but
one of my favorite stories i was playing
my first us open it was really the
granddaddy of all swiss tournaments in
the united states at the time it was in
chicago i was 13.
and you know
that was weird because like there's 700
players in the tournament and i was
looking at the pairing sheets and i was
trying to find my name you know all the
way down on board like 200 or something
like that so i go off to the playing
hall there's a nice elderly gentleman at
the board a big smile big beautiful
white teeth
shook my hand warmly and we started
playing and during the game
you know he really began grimacing
exposing his teeth more and more i was
like ah
this kind of thing and then i did get
into time trouble cardinal sin
and he'd taken a glass of water and he
took his teeth out
he put him in a glass of water right
beside the board i had been steering
these t
for three hours and suddenly they were
on the side of the board
could you say i was distracted
i was only 13 and
there's these teeth staring back at me
it was pretty
pretty hard
holding two hands up
okay well finish this oh you got the
position that you wanted to
yeah it's not the exact position but
it's very similar to what happened in
the game so basically i'm
i'm black uh i'm white in this position
against a player who's a couple hundred
radio points below me right and i'm just
getting toasted i mean right right yes
it calls down
but i see a trick and it's it's similar
again to this position but it's not
quite the position so i'm go he's going
to play rook here and start pushing i'm
in big trouble so i
this is what happened before i moved
i'm sitting there and i'm just
this is i've seen it it's even deeper
than this actually
but i'm sitting there like this is over
right
side
yeah
all right whatever and i play rocket
and i write my move down you know one of
those limp wrist facts right whatever
life's about this just put me out of my
music just finish it off and he just
nicely plays rook to asics and then
and i make one of these kind of king e2
moves you know it's just right
yeah and i play one of these king e3
moves and i just
and he's just like
this guy
and he plays this move right and
nothing to be done i just played my
rookie one you know just just play the
move so i can resign
and do place 82. and you and i belong
yeah baby and i played rook takes a2
and his shoulders went
right oh
it was bad and the whole acting job i
put on before i was like shameful
shameful but no shame in this game thank
you very much
it was painful so yeah sometimes
you to do what you got to do
it's terrible it's terrible i couldn't
be ashamed of it but you know what
you're feeling really good
right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and i should point out for the fans
rook takes rook is a stalemate i got no
moves yeah no moves what would you like
me to do what would you like me to do
a very very similar story i don't know
the exact position it was uh zoltan
ripley
was killing boris baskey like just
killing killing and boris was doing
everything that you just described
depressed like boy i wonder what i'm
gonna have for dinner tonight oh do i
really have to move okay
like this
and he set up one of the greatest
cheapos of a stalemate i had ever seen
and sultan went right into it
and when zoltan i mean the head hit the
table
no
but zoldan uh to his credit
immediately started laughing yeah you
said like well done well done
um
by the way uh
before and this i think was very
important before fabi could establish
his bishop on d4
and his pawn on f3 that's the ideal
position he wants a great bishop for
himself
not a great bishop for his opponent
peter svidler
peter just laid down the gauntlet and
said you can't play f3 if you play f3
well you'll leave your bishop hanging
and i'll get away with bishop takes and
yes you can touch my queen but then i've
got queen g5 and you can't
capture my bishop so bishop e4
is literally the most challenging move
for white because he's not being offered
the easy way of getting his pawn to f3 i
don't see a way to get the pawn to f3
because bishop d4 allows the move queen
g5 and that's some sort of transposition
you kind of have to play f3 you could
play g3 but you really don't want to
that's when you when that bishop
suddenly looks a lot better than your
bishop on d4 no absolutely i cannot
play g2 g3 i think that if you're going
to try for an advantage here you have to
pawn grub
if you don't take on b6 i really don't
know what we could be doing exactly and
then you've got to always be careful
that you're not allowing some kind of a
perpet
where the bishop takes uh to
a kind of
shot i don't think it's in the position
yes why actually because the queen on b6
is defending the bishop on e3 let's take
a look at this line bishop takes g2 for
example exactly take that queen e4 check
now if the king has to retreat it's at
least a perpetual yeah and that's easy
per patch actually might be winning for
black people
exactly you might have a rook a rover
yeah but instead because the queen is
defending this bishop now on from b6 to
e3 you have to move f3 for yourself
right queen e4 check f3 and i don't
automatically get to capture this bishop
because of what you just said
this looks like you have to take on b6 i
don't know how good it is to take the
pawn but i don't see another move
right and so i'm scared
oh you start to feel like it's not it's
not my pieces
right right right
uh i
think it's okay though i think it's
queen d4 at least it's okay all the
queen before you trade and go rook a6 is
not
not really
what i wanted right yeah this is one of
those uh things where you
one of my favorite tactics and it's so
rare it's the windmill tactic
you know the old uh
unfortunately the windmill tactic is
just not working here this is the
windmill tactic that i'm talking about
where you get to force the guy into a
check and you get the discovery check
and you get to wipe them out the problem
is is that the bishop is hanging
though
i don't know very very sad
although
that's kind of a funny rook and bishop
in two points no i got paige pawn what
am i talking about not even close no
exactly
but
okay uh
a challenge
definitely throwing down the gauntlet is
the move bishop e4 and
well if you don't take the pawn like you
say
you can't play f3 no for reasons we just
discussed you can't play bishop d4
moving the rook makes no sense
moving the rook from f1 also makes no
sense uh at least to my mind because i
really don't think
now i start to worry that that that
how do you say a rook sacrifice
might suddenly show up in my doorstep
and i'm sitting there saying well
why why what does i do
why did i sign up for this i mean the
bishop on e4
is a monster in such
cases so okay um we'll leave that one
to
uh
percolate and i really did want to get
back into our marquee match-up game
because mvl and uh wesley even though
the position may not be the most
exciting position uh i'm curious to see
how the players continue well guess what
g6 played
tonight goes to g7 solidifying that
position the knight retreats 3-2 but
notice there was no queen f6 no queen f6
perhaps wesley did evaluate the endgame
as wars for him needs to get his pieces
out
unpleasant yeah because well i mean
i may be on a good day i can go queen h6
if i get a bunch of moves in i win right
queen h6 knight f4 and knight h5 it's a
lot of moves it's a dream right
uh let me play a bad move and i love the
move knight h5 because of this one
varasing surprise and that's it you
can't take my rook that's made in one
and black has issues so
yeah well the build up still some issues
for blackout right so maybe i have to do
something like it's i think it's about
time to start especially with the knight
on e2 cutting
the rook on e1 from action right maybe
it's time to play f6 but it's not the
happiest of moves you do retreat to e3
thank you for your weakness on e6 it
might not be the biggest of deals but
i'll start thinking about it queen f7
maybe i can't even consider queen d6
yeah that was the thing i was going to
say look let me
somehow with the knight on e2 it's like
that one moment that i get to maybe kick
your queen just around a little and
well okay but once again it's the
risk-free event completely risk-free for
nbl all white an extra 20 minutes on the
clock okay we don't think that
it's a very big advantage but but
because from wesley's point of view a
draw is so huge right and that's the
weird thing because if you look at the
tournament standings you would think
it's wesley that's wanting to wanting to
win with everyone missing playing the
single field cup but we're playing for
more than that this is the final
tournament of the 2021 grand chess tour
and it has been an exciting one but it's
pretty much down to these two players
wesley having a considerable lead over
mvl a draw is what the doctor ordered if
wesley wants to win the entire tour and
one hundred thousand dollar bonus money
yes of course the sinkhole cup winning
ninety thousand dollars or winning sixty
thousand yeah that's a big gap but guess
what securing the one hundred thousand
dollar and all of the prestige that
comes with winning the sinkhole cup
winning the grand chest or what pardon
me winning the grand chest store uh yeah
wesley
says okay i'll suffer a little
for an advantage disadvantage that maybe
i can handle and we'll see if he can
handle it we're going to take a small
break here in the studio we'll be right
back with more action of round eight of
the sinkfield cup but we're going to
leave you with a special it's a parkside
chat oh was it one of our disc or with
maurice or you guys they didn't tell me
we're gonna have to find out with the
audience they were pretty fun stay tuned
we'll be right back
[Music]
maurice what a pleasure chess in the
parks chess in the parks this is where i
grew up playing chess like for me this
is this is home playing in new york city
playing in brooklyn prospect park
uh even into manhattan washington square
park it was always a lot of fun oh for
me it's always been like that i've had
the pleasure of playing around the world
in different parks and you get to meet
this real hustlers you can see their
tactics their tricks it's been amazing
and
i think new york has the trickiest ones
man those guys in in new york city they
have mastered the art of the hustle
first of all there's always got to be
trash talking like there's no chess
without trash talking we play in the the
club we do commentary in the club and
everybody's quiet and all no
you better take your feelings and park
them somewhere because guys are going to
talk about your mama about your sister
about your best friends and about your
chess moves and you have to be on top of
stuff
i've seen players they're beat up titled
players that come in their confidence
trotting like they know what's going on
they say
park players amateurs i can beat them up
i've seen them you know go home being
just on the receiving end of some nasty
tricks well the legends of the park you
got guys like
vinnie livermore
ralph mouth
lightning sam all these guys they knew
how to get inside your head the point is
you think you're playing chess but
you're listening to them at the same
time they know just the right thing to
say to throw you off and there's an art
to that there's an art to distraction
that's what it's all about when you're
playing and then you have like the nasty
tricks sometimes in the old school
jurgers you know the analog clocks
somehow your side would move a little
faster like wait a minute how come my
time is down already or you got the
hustle where when it got down to the
blitz how suddenly all the moves they
made were close to the clock every move
every move is on the side of the clock
so that your flag would fall before
theirs did it was always some kind of
trickery to get your money out of your
pocket money out of your pocket but i
think you've gone around new york how
did it feel the experience of playing
against them man i was playing in the
park and i get my butt kicked getting my
money taken my lunch money taken by
these guys it was just the way you
learned it was just part of being a
chess player in the parks not only also
with the trash talking scene you had a
bunch of guys just hanging out sometimes
ladies you'd have music playing you'd be
saying sirens police cars were going by
i'm talking about this was the hood
fulton park as well
and we would just that would be normal
for us so to me that kind of cutthroat
atmosphere
where it was all about winning and you
might get your money taken really
prepared me for what would come when i
was in clubs and you know nobody be
quiet
everything was just high-end yeah for me
it was the same way i grew up a blitz
player i went to in costa rica and i
just played gangsters you know they
would like hustle for absolutely no
money but that was all they had
and i had to learn how to be tricky i
was actually had to slow myself down
when i became a norm hunter because i
was just playing too quickly and too
tricky uh but it's always been part of
my culture as well and i love going
around the world to different parks and
just seeing
people play luxembourg park absolutely
paris absolutely gorgeous
around moscow you can see people playing
all over i had a great time in avana and
i was just going around the park and i
saw i wasn't even planning on going to
play chess and i was just seeing some
people you know playing for fun i
checked it out
man they were good
man they were solid chess players you
can see the tags you can see the tricks
they were playing some theory i was like
not easy anymore part chess can't be
underestimated you know it's funny when
i was playing i remember what the the
park players they used to try to play in
tournaments right but even playing in
tournaments they tried to hustle it
right they keep their ratings down they
wouldn't they you know under
these guys were 2200 strength in blitz
but you know it was funny because they
wouldn't be able to sit still for hours
on end they'd be like yo make a move man
because they're used to going like this
so they'd be sitting there and they'd
come out they would rarely win big money
at those tournaments there was a
difference between park chess and
serious over-the-board tournaments yeah
and they and they would tell me to try
to keep my braiding down i was like come
on i'm trying to get my grandmaster i'm
not gonna keep my rating low but it was
always about the hustle and that would
keep them back they would keep them back
but man they are tricky sometimes you
see them play against strong players
i would say even up to videomaster
international master level and you'd see
man the 1600 um you know that's not
right so that is absolutely not right
how do they know so many tricks and
sometimes the positional understanding
it's not there it's that flick of the
wrist i'm gonna trip you i'm gonna trick
you and
very dangerous people auto tactics
matter of fact there's a video of me
playing a hustler in washington square
park and he tried to take well i won't
spoil it for people who would watch it
just to say he did a move i'd never seen
tried
ever like ever in the history of my
playing chess it is after years and
years i mean decades of playing and i
played this game i saw i was like
this guy actually pulled this hustle
trying to cheat in the middle of a game
and i respected him for it i was like
that was funny like you actually
practiced that and tried to pull it off
he could have done it a lot better i
still would have seen it but it was a
great great move
i i think it's just a resourcefulness
when it comes down to it the practice of
being resourceful at so many different
things in chess and i love the
creativity they bring to it it's the
clock it's the tactic it's the it's the
doom i'm not really sure we're in the
pieces i love that one it could be on
two four squares at once four squares no
my bishop just changed color what are
you talking about in the middle you're
like wait how did that bishop i thought
it was a white square bishop no it's a
dark square bishop stuff like that is
just priceless and you gotta lend for to
fend for yourself nobody's gonna be like
yeah of course that bishop no you gotta
fight for your rights in those games
there's no arbiter to call over hey
chris bird can i have some adjournment
no
no
german
you're you're in the middle of the war
and it's fun like i said the trash
talking
the joy of the game the fun of it and
the cutthroat aspect you'll see people
standing around the chessboard in a park
and watching
like they're watching magnus cross and
play hikaru nakamura because people are
showing off it's the when hikaru and
magnus and all these guys they play a
brilliant move you know they played and
they they might adjust their piece a
little bit more than another you're on a
party like boom baby i'm here to play
chess come watch i'm playing this
brilliancy it's just a different
atmosphere and the language uh will get
a little um
you know let's just say we can't talk
talk about that when we're at the st
louis chess club yeah but
the flamboyance and the language guys
would be quoting shakespeare
you were like who's this guy and they're
mixing in street with
old school classical
everything it's just i i think i think
it would make a great show
if it was all about purchase it would i
think i made great tv maurice i'm
getting fired up let's let's play some
chats let's do it
give me a break this is a boring this is
how you play chess oh my sister plays
better than this you don't even know how
to play chess do you want the best from
the fourth record
out of here that lady ain't got nothing
backwards come on give me a break
forward oh this guy do you know how to
pass the fourth rank
[Music]
i'm emily allred curator at the world
chess hall of fame
in august 2021 people around missouri
commemorated the state's bicentennial as
part of these celebrations a life-size
granite chess board will be installed at
a new park on adrian's island in
jefferson city missouri
surrounding the board will be 32 images
representing the contributions that
missourians have made in varied fields
including agriculture
music
literature
and sports
the board will also educate visitors
about significant historical moments and
personalities from the state's history
including president harry s truman dredd
and harriet scott's courageous efforts
to gain their freedom innovations of
george washington carver
the project was spearheaded by dr
jeannie karen sinkfield the co-founder
of the st louis chess campus
the chessboard is the eagle scout
project for andrew dowden a life scout
and student at helios catholic high
school in jefferson city missouri he
completed the engravings on the stone
surrounding the chessboard using an
epilogue laser at the scouts bsa
invention campus
around the board will be benches made
from 200 year old wood by life scout
maya thomas a student at kirksville high
school in kirksville missouri as a part
of her eagle scout project
on august 9th the efforts of both scouts
were honored during a ceremony
commemorating the dedication of the
bicentennial bridge which was attended
by governor mike parson lieutenant
governor mike kehoe and the mayor of
jefferson city kerry turgeon
a free brochure is available on site at
the world chess hall of fame
and for download at worldchesthof.org
it contains passages about the
historical moments memorialized on each
of the squares as well as information
about the efforts of the scouts who made
this project a reality
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the eighth round of the
sink field cup before we get into the
action we want to make a small
commercial
support us here at our show we have some
awesome swag for you take a look at this
capital
of chess in america t-shirt of course
the gateway to the west st louis here we
are proud of what we do join us here
match with some of the players they love
this shirt i know a lot of players
including fabiano carrana wear this
pretty often running around the central
west end you can get this at
qboutiquestl.com you want something more
unique
check it out yasser's got it for you
it's a commemorative board of the 2021
singfield cup signed by all of the
players who even get a certificate of
authenticity with to go with it but
there's a very very limited edition of
the players i mean we didn't really want
to sit them down and say you know give
us you know 50 or anything like that
very very limited edition so it's a
first-come first-served basis so you
better get in your orders yeah and take
it away from yasser because i know
hillary's gonna steal one and put it in
his bag
you gotta buy it like the rest of us
i've got a man cave that just
needs needs this type of art on it on
the wall on the wall right
qboutiquestl.com
all of this and a lot more merchandise a
lot more swag join us uh
match with us right now right match with
the player seriously and speaking of the
players let's see what's transpired
while we were on break do we have any
videos that much news to report at least
as far as the mdl versus wesley claim is
concerned i mean we all identified what
the problem for mvl is this knight on c3
is basically not participating you got
to find the square
g5 would be nice if we saw variation
with the knight went to h5 in any way
it's got to go knight c3 e2 rook a e8
preparing
moves like f7 and f6 in order to
challenge
the e-file uh the chopping block the
soviets uh called open files where
rooks could get captured and traded off
the board that's what wesley has done
and mvl is thinking okay
so i have space i have a few things in
my favor but how do i get more how do we
proceed against cavemen chess let's just
go queen h6 right hope i can mate the
guy absolutely checkmate is the ideal
and um
[Music]
yes
absolutely i wanna hang i want to hang
with you on the king's side actually i
don't want to see that knight f4 knight
h5 you can go there but then i'll trade
nights and i'll drop back with my queen
and keep
everything under control
shall we continue
and i kind of like what you had
suggested before that borrowing a page
from hari krishna's game uh the move
h2h4
makes a lot of sense uh to my eyes and
you can play like this
if you like
maybe
could i have gotten away
with the move bishop f5 because that's
what i really want to do is just trade
as much as i could yeah and trading
light squared bishops
would be a dream and if knight h5
knight h5 i've got to take that there's
no question about that
and
you
oh
no you can't play that no i can't play
that well that answers that question
thank you knight h5 is a winner so i did
have to play bishop back and you could
if you wanted continue h4 i'm still not
so sure how much better if better at all
white is it does seem more pleasant but
mvo has chosen instead the move knight
g3 after which wesley surprisingly
quickly plays the move queen d6 wow
okay so then
oh not queen h6 pardon me
knight g3 was mvl's choice again
um
i always kind of wonder
you know
what the best
circuit is for the knight
the move knight g3 is not intuitively
obvious to me because the
the squares i want to go to they're
already covered or by pollens right so i
would have thought in my mind that the
that knight g3 wasn't the best square
and i would have thought knight f4 would
have been a better score but knight g3
queen d6 immediately immediately
it has nice it has a very clear threat
f7 f6 i want to trade queens or maybe
win a rook
you still would have rook five e4 but
yeah but it's not what you want to play
in this position no a very clear threat
already by wesley the first one of the
game
if you move the queen this is the
chopping block story that i was
referring to a moment ago
as the rooks are now favorites to come
off the board unless
no knight h5 no it does not work
because the rook is defended too many
times by both
sets of minor pieces the only thing you
have to work
worry about in such positions is you
constantly keep calculating does bishop
takes g6 work or not but hence
you know to be on the very very safe
side of the story you might even
consider a very solid move like bishop
that's ultra safe but i don't see the
problem with it it does seem like too
many things are going to come off on the
f file i would love to keep that rook on
e5 but i think this is why wesley
doesn't want to involve himself with any
queen f6 action is that he wants to keep
the option of putting the pawn on f6 as
the only way of really removing the rook
from e5 open to himself
fair maurice what do you have for us
you know i'm thinking about something
you guys can help me out
i'm impressed that he thinks we can help
him out
i just need a supporting cast okay
we're ready we're ready here's the deal
yep
if fabi
if wesley draws this game okay
and fabi draws this game we've been
in his game we've been talking we had
all those scenarios at the top of the
show right and i'm starting to think
there's a simple scenario
that goes wesley draws fabie draws
the grand chess tour is over
now this one is looking
very close i mean very very close this
pawn is weak for sure this bishop though
is creating some pressure you don't want
to necessarily play f3 because of the
additional pressure there and this pawn
is you know it's got some we're still
not in in total draw land yet but
definitely
this position is very close to a juror
okay if fabi draws and wesley also draws
against mvl
i think the grand chester is done
because
because fabian richard play tomorrow
right
and if that's the case uh a fabi
could let's say richard even wins his
game
if richard wins his game he he will be
he will be a point it will be a a half a
point behind wesley is that correct no
he was a point behind yeah he would be a
half a point in the case of a draw
but he and fabi both can't gain points
to leapfrog wesley right that's the key
will every wesley has to drop all the
way to fifth in case mvo wins the event
but we also thought tied for fourth
doesn't make it right
is tied for fourth a problem also i
think that for fourth is a problem
time for fourth if we can get that
graphic up on the gct points that you
get as soon as you guys can that would
be great not the standings but how many
points you get
for a
placement so the price distribution of
the sink field cup yeah the price
distribute the 325 thousand dollars in
the sink fill cut but we also want to
take a look at the third column the gct
points 13 points for a clear win and
where
our discussion is mbl is a clear winner
with 13. now
what we're talking about is
does west wesley need
six and a half points because that's
what what he would get for tied for
and i don't think that cuts it and he
would tie with let's say two players
would only get six and he needs six
point
seven
six no or was it six point three six
point three we'll have a graphic for
that as well but i don't think i don't
we're just saying i think i know what
you're saying so i think if if they both
draw today they'd be tied
right if richard wins and then he wins
again he overtakes wesley
and wesley would still be tied with fabi
yes and depending on what lanier does
and if everybody else moves up then that
type of fourth is a problem mm-hmm see
that's why i ask for your help see that
there you go yeah we're useful i'm not
sure i helped you did amazing yes
amazing math skills by the legend
i'm not
very good very good very good uh
well
why do you say fabby's position is so
equal
well i'm not saying it's so equal but
the problem is that obviously we were
looking at queen takes b6 was our main
move maurice and we didn't think peter
had a forced uh perpetual
uh by any sacrifices but we weren't sure
either no nothing forced necessarily but
the problem is how do you get this rook
off of this square
well this is where we wanted to play f3
now that the bishop is fully defended on
e3
we couldn't do it when the queen was on
b4 all right well let's play full
defense
and take your bomb that's not the what
what
well the invasion
and now you start defending your own
position that is some alien chess rook
a4 bishop takes f3 and rook
we haven't we or have we left the
building f1 camp g you can't play you
can't play rookie yeah because that's
hanging you can't play queen b2 because
that's covered the geometry of this
could be unable to defend
and now suddenly rook g4 check now you
can't go in the corner because we need
four right now you got to go here and no
this is incredible
brutal nice
[Music]
tactically holding position together and
preparing a double
and stopping f3
is this brilliancy prize up for grabs
because if anything like this occurs on
the board we've got to give peter
surprise
peter spiller plays this i'm gonna go up
to him and be like you're one of my best
friends dude
but did you did you cheat
rook a4 bishop through rook h41
okay go go back to the position after
rook a4 and you're telling me that rook
a4 i i get it rook a4 threatens d4
threatens bishop takes uh g2 other
things but there's a lot of stuff you
just said this and this that's like oh
that's a lot of stuff maybe it is too
much stuff and you find and he's taking
it
hey peter
if we see rook a4 land on the board and
by the way is it forced for
black to hold that equality i'm sure he
has a lot of moves in this position of
course more sane moves i would say yeah
well
well no rook a4
rookie for rook a3 or the type of moves
yeah i would be my eyes what else would
you play right because hitting the queen
and like keeping the pawn on a2
well actually we were thinking of rook
have sex but they didn't really really
refute it did we i think we were going
to go queen d4 or you saying but say
takes takes root cafe six and f3 and i
get the g7
tickle
do you though yes you guys just do raw
variations
okay let me put it on let me bring it up
on my screen over here queen takes b6
so
the move rook a4 is extraordinary
and really visual once you start to
drill deeper and see why
this rook
amazingly enough goes from that's crazy
a8 to h4 in like a superman leap
like that how did you do that also the
geometry yeah that there is no defense
on h2 right because the queen on e5
attacks the rook on a1 so you can't use
the rook you that queen on e5 covers b2
yeah and it hits a1 uh we'll we'll get
into that but what we thought was rook
f6
and here i was just saying to
alejandro that i would think
that in this type of variation
yeah i still have something going on
with white because after f3 you're going
to win back this a2 pawn but
careful careful i'll get something going
with
my bishop poster that was that's very
true but do you
i play king f7
and we still we
will be fighting for another
maybe you could play rook a4 uh right
back here no alejandro
you had rookie three didn't you
rookie three i want to play a3 and just
guard the pawn that's what i'm saying oh
no
i warm up to that yeah i was i don't
know
i know
yeah i was to go here and and
pretend that uh what's wrong with
keeping your palm and nothing is wrong
with this movie no keeping your pawn i
like especially the past
so we thought that
rook f6 well a very human move and rook
f6
ideas of rook g6 make a lot of sense the
move queen d4 king comes with gain of
tempo
conversely
this
move and once again we're going to put
this on the board because it is such a
vision
f3 and white thinks i've got this game
under control until
his world gets rocked bishop takes f3
you cannot take with the rook
don't leave this rook hanging so you
take the bishop with the pawn and then
suddenly and shockingly
this rook comes over and you can't
defend f2 queen b2 alejandra
the queen queen queen queen b2 the
desired queen b2 is
you can't play rook f2 once again the a
rook it's amazing so
you play
you block the threat of mate
queen h2 with a move f4 and suddenly you
discover
you can't go into the corner king h1
queen e4 is a mate you've got to take a
walk and you don't go you don't get very
far
you can you can run but you can't hide
yeah you're about to check me this is
incredible that's
that is a tall like attack from a clear
blue sky like out like
why why why is this why does this work
right rook a4 this is an amazing move
and maurice uh explain yourself
how dare you uh
how dare i tell you what to do
i got something else oh bring it on
all right let's go let's go so rook a4
we know as a point the engine gives the
move h3
guarding the g4 square okay
no bishop g2 no rook g4 got it right it
sees all of that so it says all right
i'll stop you down here you don't get to
make sense so of course
it it doesn't give this next move but
it's natural i'm going to play it the
normal human movement
rook's hanging out oh the rook is
hanging he's hanging queen bee check
hold on d5 hmd5
on e3 not queen e4 but takes on e3 yeah
i think that if you played queen e4 f3
you get my bishop but that's that's the
end of the world right okay but go on
so now it's your move how do you defend
i'm gonna go queen g4 to just stay close
to my king uh be careful with queen g4
because this takes is a free pawn that
pawn that rook on a1 you you put my rook
on a1
at the beginning blame chris bird the
arbiter putting that broken a1 he's been
sitting there yeah
so
don't make your instinctive move just
yet where are my i'm back back here here
with the bishop
having just been captured
so
we
[Music]
wow we move our rook somewhere but i
think that rook needs to cover
something
all right okay i move my rook
rook c1 just i'm going to pick square
that's the first move that's the very
first one it's got to go somewhere right
but it's got to go somewhere
specifically don't go anywhere crazy
like here where you lose on this side
here where you get four right you got to
pick between these two so you're going
to think which one should i but it
cannot be b1 because at the end of the
variation queen f5 queen takes b1 picks
up the rook another point so this move
uh it's not quite clear what you just
said though you want to take on this
square it takes takes and takes and this
looks
pretty much like it's sorry king takes
like it's going to win the game the
problem is the king can move and you
can't take here because of this oops
at the very end of the line
so
so b1 is in the mix let me go back to
the top be what is in the mix but we'll
go with the engine's first move this one
let's see what and now what do you do
about queen g5 and this position queen
g4 everybody's gonna play queen g four
right that was with a little bit of a
like give me dude wait a minute okay i
can't wait to take on that one because
the rook's on c1 wait right where does
rook always hang out
the king now moves we borrow this guy
from you we borrow this guy from you
what do you think about this endgame you
will lose this pawn
but are we lost
i would think so i wouldn't want i
wouldn't voluntarily jump into it well
hold on because yeah i guess this move
can be met by g5 you don't want to get
this one away because that is a draw
right g5 and
this end game
with this pawn on g5 is problematic the
point being this move doesn't work
because of this capture and you can't
get the pawn back because my pawn is on
g5 i can't get my king to h6 i can't
walk my king to h6 so it might be rook
and bishop draw
wow what a lot of variation
why stuff but peter didn't go for rook
a4 he played like a human and played
rook to f6 yeah i think this is both of
us suspected right it's the most natural
move in the position rook f6 rover with
a gain of tempo against the queen how
could you not do that rook a4 on the
other hand
uh
covering the d4 square
strong move
not only is a real strong movie i mean
you you can find justifications for it
without rook h4 as well um
wow okay that's a big big game a game
that's slipping under our radar too is
lanier dominguez's game i just wanted to
say
this gentleman is having the tournament
i don't want to save the cr of his
career because he has such an
illustrious career already but he's
undefeated and he's in the mix for first
thing about lanier dominguez he's a
player that's always been up there top
i want to say he's been top 50 for
ever right it seems like it seems like
right but
out in classical chess of course he is
an incredibly successful rapper and
blitz player including a victory at the
world blitz championship he's a world
champion
but which major tournament has linear
one
he was so close to winning a u.s
championship i remember he was close
lots of seconds and i think he's hungry
for actually winning
yeah a big title sink field cup
uh would definitely be a huge feather
well i mean in anybody's resume but i
understand what you're saying yeah you
really want that victory there right so
you put on a resume so when you say he's
close he's closing in on the top 10 and
i believe he's been in the top 10 before
correct but he hasn't won like a super
world-class event clear first no
something
that's extraordinary consistent
but not always a bridesmaid kind of
thing that then never first yeah i can't
really remember the last time he won a
big event he of course he does very well
he's done really well in world cups he's
done really well in many other events
he's gone really well in grand prix
events i believe he even tied for first
in one of them
but actually winning the whole thing
clear
okay and how is he doing with sam
shanklin that's the big question when we
left it we left it just around these
parts bishop c4 knight c6 i think was
the exact moment
immediate knight d5 by the way we've
talked about the battle over the d5
square and knight d5 now
the desirable knight takes e4 has a
major problem bishop b6
comes with the tempo knight c7 check is
going to cost material hence we saw
castles bishop b6 queen d7
knight takes f6 and the players have
quickly or
maybe not so quickly
achieved this position castles on
opposite sides
um
i don't know first impression i like
white first impressions is very
dangerous for black
and by the way they're a lifetime score
between these two players i can't
imagine there's many games right a u.s
championship whoa
that's less games than i thought
actually
no no blood spilled no blood spilled but
can this be the first one let's go back
to the position i don't oh maurice you
have some insights here yes please well
we could talk about the position for
sure you guys do it feel free to do it i
just wanted you to pay careful attention
to the clock times oh big very careful
attention
linear doing a pulling a linear and that
is it's only 14 moves that have been
played there are 26 moves out of this
incredibly rich position left for him to
make his time control the first time
control
26 moves
would you say that's a lot of moves
that's a lot of moves
in this rich
crazy position
lanier has only 38 minutes left 38. 38.
he's only played 14 moves and he's got
only 38 minutes left of course he gets
the increment but we know that means
nothing the time is going to further
away very very fast as you try to make
each and every move coming out of this
position
he he doesn't he barely has a little
over a minute in change for each move
from this it's like the
you could have blitzed out these moves
it seems like you just get to this at
least the first 10. i mean
yeah extraordinary thing if there is a
weakness in lanier's game it has to be
as is clock mismanagement
by the way
at first eight he still had more time
than he started with the first statement
yeah that's right first of all in the
next six the next six spent
about an hour 52 minutes jeez
52 million no time because an increment
was lost in the first eight moves the
next six 58 minutes
hours just on move 14. so that's a
problem for him i i mean sam's got to
feel a lot better but sam himself is
spending some time he has 50 plus
minutes but it's not nearly as bad as
little bit addressing the position
okay now obviously i want to play queen
takes d6 and equally obviously i can't
do it at this moment as my bishop on c4
is hanging but
it really is my desire to play queen
takes d6 don't play a move like rook d8
and leave the pawn on f7 hanging i'm
thinking queen
b3 it would be a very good response to
that poor decision rook f8 so sam this
knight on e7 needs a job right like
would you play here in order to be able
to
bring your bishop back and maybe reroute
the knight to a better square i would
never idea i would never leave the d5
square fully in white's control i feel
that for black to properly play this
position you need to at least have
somebody watching over that square okay
i don't think we can give it up
completely i don't like for example
knight g6 okay uh
i'm not right now right away but the
idea of g3 coming with h4
g3 if you go on ig6 i mean oh i think
your knight is just not well played you
you're saying that
something could
could cause distress all right well
then the alternative that you might
offer me would be fine do you think this
is the
uh you take my pawn i take your pawn
okay i'm not sure what to evaluate the
endgame asks
i don't know i wouldn't be too happy
going into the end game as white i feel
i'm slightly better but i also feel like
i should be getting more out of the
position i would consider with black
even taking on d6 first like trading
trading queens and just going into
this kind of a position mainly because
it might be you do give me possession of
the d file i do in this case
i can pretend i have some counter play
myself or an a5 yeah yeah yeah and
knight f5 f5 as well so after the move
bishop b7
for me i'm kind of not
really
enthusiastic about this guy
um could i just have a quick gander at
this one
all right i obviously can't take it but
i can also take on e4 to begin with and
we do have the most b5 bishop b3 already
bishop and bishop b7 sometimes we get
one right it's not the commentator's
curse in this one yay yeah
we have had our moments we've had
terrible moments on set i mean i've been
very proud of our miscues i mean not
everybody can have the miscues that
we've had in this tournament but
wow what games we've experienced so the
idea obviously is i yes i'm willing to
go into this ending because i was
thinking i was going to get two pawns
um uh for uh
yeah rook and two minor pieces i'm
giving up the minor pieces i was
wondering about that but i also was
wondering if after h6 yes kind of
typical sicilian fashion yes i just go
h4 so you can have that oh too
sophisticated for me i was being more
brutal
this is pretty brutal
okay okay i get it
nice
i'm not sure i'm threatening anything
because queen takes d6 doesn't help me i
can't leave my nightmare and we're 100
sure you know well i got to ask a
question can i take this night it's not
my piece i don't care exactly
um
now i do see that the queen is ready to
rumble
uh down the h file and i've got to do
something about that this feels a little
fast
you're telling me i'm
i'm getting on my horse i want to get
out of dodge so
something like this like
it's probably
still good right and then g6 at the end
g6 or rook h7 right
yeah
okay um okay intriguing line and it all
starts with the current position
and i tried bishop g5 i tried bishop g5
uh
my bishop on e3 my knight on f3 i don't
really think of these pieces as doing
you know a very good job at the current
time and that was why i i suggested them
a bishop g5 i like it i like it a lot
and if you go down the line of queen
take c4 in this position i think
you'll be very happy with white going
into this end game because as opposed to
the other ones we've been analyzing
there's a clear target for the rook you
have a target on f6 you have to keep
defending you have a target on a6 you
have to keep defending right this one's
all white exactly uh that i i like
white's advantages a lot back to you
maurice and this amazing fabiano game
well fabiano's not going to be happy
after rook f6 because he had to go into
this end game
and he's not going to easily advance his
pawn or even retain his pawn as there's
a variation that it is to pay attention
to and that is he's he can't let rook g6
and an attack happen that's that's going
to be bad news these sacrifices are
coming too quickly so he had to offer an
exchange of queens peter quickly
accepted the offer and put the rook a6
we had this position on the board before
on your screen right the thing is our
very natural move after f3 getting ready
to put the rook on f2
to guard the pawn on a2 can be met
directly instead of bishop d3
by bishop c2
that's sophisticated
absolutely all right we like that that's
a touch rook f2 doesn't do anything your
a pawn's simply hanging now eaten yeah
so that means now you have to go back
into this line that you said yeah so
you're already eliminated i wanted to go
rook to the g7 give me the christmas and
you were going to play remember we had
the move rookie
and being able to play a3 because the
bishop was a target on the d3 square
right not going to happen so now the
issue becomes getting down here with
some action
the problem is black can even play
disruptor right now with this move
to a4 move your bishop
your bishop starts to experience little
issues
one major point is that this pawn now
let's say you just put it here this pawn
suddenly turned into a runaway like
what
did this guy graduate right paul's going
to go to d3 you're not thinking about
winning anymore like wait wait wait he's
he's going all the way down the board
okay maybe you'll you'll handle the
position
but that's a problem where do you
want it the bishop in this position is
there any place to put the bishop bishop
here
allows rook takes a2 bishop c3 allows
the move d4 this rook a4 move is
annoying
seriously now you have to play really
sophisticated chess and according to the
engine player rook c1 bale on this pawn
look for your activity but you start to
feel like the advantage is going
slower and slower
also rook takes bishop could happen for
example in this line
this position is absolutely not easy to
be able to play
because it's double rooks and this a
pawn is advanced but it's three against
two here but these gotta pass pawn
you've gotta pass pawn looks like pass
pawns will neutralize each other and
that threatens two is going nowhere this
is looking very very close to fabi not
being able to produce any magic in this
game and likely
a draw and the same can be said by the
in the game
versus wesley so going nowhere going
nowhere the american player has fully
neutralized any attempts
wow wesley is just so good wesley's just
so solid i know he just made it look so
easy as well we kind of felt like okay
mbl's got some pressure
i mean it's it's nothing absolutely
absolutely great but you know something
that grandmasters like to work with type
of pressure after the move queen d6 we
did see queen f6 wesley said no no no no
no
let me just do that again we just got
here to knight g3
queen d6 queen f6 wesley said no this
queen really is too powerful i'll drop
back with my own queen there was a trade
and after h4
it's just like wesley's perfectly in
time
this was beautifully timed go away with
the rook
and now i'll cover the g6 pawn with this
bishop retreat and the same time trade
rooks the desirable rook e7 just walks
into what we all know
to be true you're not threatening the
pawn because this rook actually defends
this rook on e1
and
the best move is to probably trade you
can't lose a rook like this oops so
rookie 7 is no threat
and after bishop f7
the players traded and we talked about
the the the chopping block yes it's just
going nowhere
and after rookie 8 rookie 8 we have
produced not that ending with the queen
and bishop versus the queen and knight
imbalance but an absolutely even steven
game f3 knight d6 i think is on the
board king f2 and the next time he makes
it looks so so easy the next time we
talk about this game is when they shake
hands and absolutely and make a draw
completely even nothing to exploit here
for the white pieces and this is just
what wesley needs oh my god to get that
grandchester standing on the other hand
if you're an mvl fan he's still leading
the tournament yeah i mean oh it belongs
for a single cup uh victory i'll take
that any day of the week to be clear
if envious wins the tournament
and does get that 90 000
yes and he also comes in second place on
the tour that's 50. that's
140k
for two weeks work you're saying he's
buying dinner
le petit
swiss a happy meal
maybe i'm just wondering because if that
happens
and wesley comes in
tight for second or third yeah let's say
wesley comes in third somehow okay as
lanier
joins fdl let's say right right
well we're expecting fabby at this exact
moment to draw
wesley to draw and lanier
three result game
but my my argument is if if you look at
the prize money yes the prize money for
third place is 45k that's right that's
very nice
if wesley only
ties for third somehow so 45 which is
easy to imagine yeah then he only gets
37.5 okay
and
another hundred thousand hundred 137.5
not bad but if maxima wins the
tournament and gets second he gets 140
thousand dollars daddy won the
tournament he deserves it
he gets the tournament second place on
the tour he gets more money than the
tour winner in the last event now i
think that overall and it looks like
there
now they're just rushing their way
overall though
does wesley wesley does have more money
than
overall yeah
by how much we'll have to make that
match remember that maxine doesn't even
have as much as moment at the moment my
med winning that classical tournament in
bucharest right but let's be real like
there's still one game left if wesley
does something mad he's white tomorrow
against there but he's not he's not
going to try is he why
you just made that bunch of math that's
a lot of money if you pass the guy you
pass the guy that's a lot of money if he
wins the tournament and wins the tour
that's 190 thousand dollars that's uh
that's a significant difference of
course but maxine might be thinking this
is 150 k in my pocket if i come in
second
uh
i mean if i win the if i win the
tournament that's a 150 k in the pocket
160
wait 100
90 to win and 60 for as the bonus 150k
right and the players again in the mvl
uh we're seeing a
really beautiful shot of the board and
the pieces remember these
sinkfield cup commemorative sets
they are up for sale you can own your
piece of history they come with a
certificate of authenticity
signed by the players as well as the
arbiter so you can say
i own the set that
made
wesley so the 2021 grand chess store
champion oh you're an mvl fan and you're
saying
this
but this set could be the the one that
is the money one that says i got the
torch the champion the tour champion and
the cynthia cupcake by the way on one
side i do expect uh
yeah i was going to say you could play
for bishop f7 and bishop g6 trying to
trade off the light square bishops or
you could
play the far more direct f6 f5
and trade the light squared bishops in
this fashion and i'm sure the players
will discover a way of making a forced
repetition
by the way peter svidler kudos to him
has found the move bishop c2 that we
were talking about in his game against
fabiano caruana
that was the neutralizing aspect that
he needed because otherwise it was
becoming unpleasant yeah well no
especially if white ever landed a rook
but it was that disruptive move rook a4
that uh
yeah if i end up having to play a move
like rook f2 and
trying to swindle something out of this
uh
nobody believes me nobody believes me
okay hold on hold on let's get back to
the scenario there's a lot of scenarios
because these drawers are going to be
very
important to the standings
right
fabie draws yes
and wesley draws and wesley draws so it
looks like this looks like what's
happening almost but if the near wins
he's tied for first okay right right
with mvl that's two people ahead of
wesley right right yeah two people ahead
of wesley
now richard we have to assume this great
this position is crazy richard just took
it back with his pawn
report
that's attitude he's like creating i can
take with my knight in the music
i'm taking my opponent agreed to be
worse right i'll just be worse but he's
definitely let's play let's play the
game play this player has not played
well in this tournament he's won only
one game
uh in seven tries
i just gotta outplay him i gotta get it
rich the time is starting to become a
factor 43 minutes to 36. they've only
played 13 moves
13 13 moves only in this game so madness
is gonna break out in this board in uh
about hour and a half an hour and a half
madness is going to definitely be
happening on this board look how rich
the position is and
they have no time on the clock they're
going to be playing a little bit of
advanced rapid game in a moment with
little time to play this position so
richard is going all in he's saying i'm
taking with the pawn whatever let's play
chess and he's worse so you see uh he's
one of those questions the audience the
the twitter from the twitter
poll or not paul but the person who sent
in a tweet who said uh you look in your
opponent's eyes does that affect
your next move i'm sure richard he can't
even see the rest of
his face because the mask is there he
probably thought
how you feel in this tournament do you
feel lucky
you're gonna try to beat me let me just
play a wild move let's just get crazy
and just make a move pawn takes that
clearly is not the kind of move you
should be playing from a positional
standpoint but let's get back to this
business of wesley possibly losing if
lunier wins that's a big if and
we know envious making the draw that's
two players ahead of wesley wesley can't
afford to have fabi overtake him
and did we say a tie for fourth loses
for wesley as well that's true but
remember
if there's a tie for first nbl doesn't
get 13 points yeah correct he only gets
11. 11. 12 plus 10 divided by 2 he gets
11. then it's not even close so mvl
fourth tied for fourth whatever will
work for wesley right nvl needs to win
the tournament clear for wesley to have
a hypothetical chance of not winning the
grand chester but the point i think you
were making there maurice was that mvl
makes a draw today with wesley and
maintains his lead
lanier wins against sam and then goes
past wesley so then in the last round
fabby has to win against richard rapport
right to
to go past wesley as well now only three
wins
only three players go past wesley and
it's not enough
wesley has a big enough lead to keep
the grandchildren but what happens
uh what happens and by the way uh no
because we're getting a draw coming here
what happens if richard beats fabi
though
i mean these numbers are from my numbers
okay that's a different kettle of fish
all together if richard beats fabi
there's a three-way tie for third
and he gets seven points
yeah chess players are
non-mathematicians
that means i mean a draw a draw now
i don't i don't understand
which scenario
if wesley draws nothing twin if wesley
draws now yeah and fabian sounds like a
clown how does he not clinch right
i don't understand richard beats fabi he
richard would have to overtake wesley
uh by the way that i'm sure the players
how come their players haven't yeah no
it's impossible
it's impossible
might very well clinch no i see how he
would have to lose tomorrow and richard
wins that's the way but but five would
still be tied with him
yeah they've died for a fourth but ty
for fourth loses for him we said so
that's the only way right richard
richard has to win now
and then
and then uh
win tomorrow against fabi
and
mvl will have to win his final game too
winning against wesley this is the only
scenario we're talking about right right
it's very unlikely i think we're
practical the pods are so slim for
practical purposes
all those numbers are weird but also
this draw also clinches second place for
mvl
yes fabi cannot overtake him no with any
result fabi cannot separate himself he
can overtake him and even win the
tournament but he cannot separate
himself far enough right because there's
a big gap between him and fabi right now
so this draw as far as emil is concerned
in the pocket we can talk about
scenarios later but it also means he has
a free road tomorrow right he's got the
fifty thousand yeah he's got the right
he's got the guaranteed runner
and then he just has to decide does he
want to go for it to try to to try to
win the tour or does he stay
conservative and win the sink field cup
uh conservative win this thing field
black against mamedyarov
i mean it's not the worst person to try
to win
i know what i'm doing tomorrow i'm
coming into the studio and i'm going to
call a very very nice final round that's
what i'm doing uh by the way just
quickly uh jumping in it's three versus
three
against mvl mvl has
well something to talk about the bonds
but no
a very
likely draw in this game i wanted to go
to the game of lanier and
um
sam shanklin for just a moment because
uh
for me a bit of surprise that lanier in
this position did not essay the move
bishop g5 rather he went immediately for
this
uh trade and well that's
unless there's some follow-up can i play
bishop g5 anyway
i was going to go knight g5
you beat me to the punch i was going to
go with you
sorry yeah bishop g5 anyway i think so
and i can maybe tickle the rook unless
there's some beautiful exchange
sacrifice that does me wrong well i
could consider it right by take
yes
it's not my pieces yes exactly that's a
beautiful thing about being chess
commentators we can get we get to take
all of our m oops that's made in one
and here is the very end of the mvl
against wesley games boy they've hosed
the whole board haven't they well
technically black can still win correct
actually white could still win
correct
but not after the both pawns disappear
and
a draw there leaf for wesley oh yeah i
think he handled it well this is the
thing about wes he handles his pressure
so
he makes it look pretty easy when he
defends
uncomfortable positions yeah what he did
with fabi was amazing what he just did
with mvl the way he won against
derek was a model
model victory he took no risks
whatsoever is black he always was in
control and then suddenly the moment
derek made one slip it was just game
over and
he won yeah wesley that's consistency
what will consistency get you maurice
granchester
championship title apparently by the way
bishop c2 i think was overlooked by fabi
because he has not moved
in quite some time since this move
landed on the board yes his head so it's
a draw too this one is really looking
more and more drawish by the second i'm
sure fabi just can't believe it he
thought maybe grabbing that pawn on b6
would have led to something but this
move bishop c2 must have come as a
surprise to him because
he's just he's just frozen he's like
what what is that one yeah geometrically
a beautiful move bishop c2 and fabi's
doesn't have the posture of a man who
thinks that this position is winning
offering look at this
this is the like
uh turning to the game because again
richard rapport keeps popping up in a
lot of our discussions and he's made
this very controversial move g7 takes f6
and
derek could you just tell me the the the
times again it's about even 34 minutes
for darius and 36 remaining for rapport
okay that being said
excuse me he had 44 minutes before g
takes f6 no that must have taken him by
surprise 10 minutes still looking at the
board
right 10 minutes so he he was shocked by
this move and he's very little time
relatively speaking on the clock because
he's he's got to make 27 moves
now in 34 minutes mm-hmm uh actually
almost take a note for yourself like
that's
the the times of these times that time's
going very fast it's ticking and
um
take us through your thinking uh
alejandro about this position because
you you had said advantage white
and uh just explain to us what your
approach would be at the moment the one
thing that you're annoyed about of
course is the spin otherwise you don't
have that many problems tell us how you
would increase
your positional advantages i would say
there's two ways to play for white okay
the reckless one with e4 and try to blow
up the center take advantage of my king
is e5 right blow it up blow it up
somehow and the other one is the king in
the middle of the board after all right
yes yep but the other one is more
traditional i would say my opponent has
the pair of bishops let's try to trade
them off play the move bishop e2 that
gets rid of the pin
uh first of all that is an important
consideration right and you're saying
like okay i'll make a move yeah 92 let's
start trading did you want to you you do
want to trade the light square bishops i
get that but did you want to force the
trade with knight h4 that's a good
question let's analyze knight h4 just
for consistency's sake please like we
will force this bishop off the board
let's trade trade and i feel
you don't have the better pair of pieces
the knight on d7 it doesn't have a good
anchor square and more than that you
kind of took away the f6 square not
entirely sure you want to play f5 and
allow e4 type of situation as you could
right but it's a consideration to make
if you ever castle queen side you have
to be worried about b4 b5 you have to be
worried about a rook coming to c1 i
don't see the king
being super safe at any point in this
position
i'm warming up tonight h4
but we have a special guest in studio
absolutely the leader of the sing field
cup we have maxima shirley graf
playing a wonderful tournament indeed is
the french superstar maxine vashila grav
maximum this position i have on the
board right now uh pretty dead you came
in with a bit of a novel idea with b3
bishop a3 queen f3
did you feel like there was going to be
real action on the board with this idea
i was hoping so um i faced it
with black against david baravian in the
world cup in some rapid game
um and i don't know i felt like i have
lots of pressure but
um
wesley played some
good moves i thought
the way he played with g6 knight g7
it wouldn't never been time to play f6
but the problem is after qd6 i don't
have queen h6 because f6 knight h5 let's
get that to the board yeah
this is a critical moment so
um
yeah like g3 here
i'm not completely sure actually that
that was correct maybe i should go queen
d2 but it also didn't felt like it's
enough
um
condition to go knight f4 of course
but yeah this shouldn't be much and the
thing is after 26
intended queen h6
f6 knight h5
but you just take on h5 you play rook e7
and
maybe i'm like
i have problems because
the wookon h5 is not comfortable and i
don't have rocky also that's important
because you take
and after g3 of bishop g4 curving
so then i exchanged queens and well
given the tournament situation i was not
gonna take too
expensive
explain that to us given the tournament
situation you say you're not going to
take too many risks
um well of course like it's a situation
that permitted me to to get more
initiative i would have played nobody
but i don't think it's wise to you know
in an equal position to force things
because i'm alpha point ahead
so no no reason to escape
are you still thinking grand chess tour
or a second place which looks like
you've wrapped up second place uh
no no no
on the tour i'm talking
doesn't really matter honestly but
i'm more thinking about tournament
victory
you want you want to win it all
i mean at this point i might as well try
uh if lanier wins today and there's a
tie for first
your efforts to go into tomorrow's game
knowing he's got he's got black against
wesley
um
you know
we'll take it step by step anyway i'm
playing uh showers black tomorrow so
definitely it will be
that's
also why i was hoping to put in more
pressure today but uh it wasn't the case
all right well thank you very much for
joining us and good luck tomorrow uh
maxine i have a quick question for you
because i just wanted to
uh ask you for your judgment
on the following variation you've just
played the move queen f3
in here
in studio alejandro and i were we're
looking at an exchange sacrifice
we wanted to ask your opinion of what
you thought about the move knight f5
bishop takes
f8 knight takes d4 well you might guess
that this isn't my notes
you had prepared queen
takes
f6 well it is a move
okay
it is it is a move it is
not revealing not spilling out those
variations very nice very nice we we got
it we enjoyed ourselves let's put it
that way uh thank you and good luck uh
tomorrow maxine thank you very much well
wonderful wonderful event one of the
most
decisive players
he could be the first to find the
historic history
note
no player has ever won the sing phil cup
having lost a game that would be amazing
and the only person that could prevent
that there's two people still in the
running linear and wesley have not lost
a game in this tournament so far right
so they're still in the running
it may happen now speaking about lanier
for just a moment he is stuck he's stuck
but
the time still a factor that's what i'm
saying 21 minutes for the remaining
23 moves
what would say that again please 21
minutes
for the remaining 23 moves he's playing
at a rate of a minute and move plus
increment okay and that's not very
comfortable i understand it's an ending
game i understand it's a little bit more
simplified
probably you won't be
calculating tons and tons of variation
right yeah but
you gotta move dude i know
the clock becomes such a factor that
sometimes you just kind of like
the brain uh just freezes and
it it can cause a massive accident but
once again we have
in studio our tour leader our tour
leader wesley soh
indeed leading the grand chess tour is
wesley so wesley
were you concerned by the speed with
which he was moving initially and this
line did it come as a surprise to you at
all yeah that's true i didn't expect he
won today i think maximus played
a few lines generally he sticks to
to his lines is very principled uh he
doesn't but today i'm surprised he
played rookie one uh i thought he would
go for the end game or some d3 stuff
um so so yeah surprising but i
actually then i like this d4
like knight fit three
this was the ending that you had
prepared probably all day and all night
for
not not all day but
all night
okay but yeah also like max famous very
principal they could also play bishop c4
and move through the piano oh yes and
also it's very complex i thought that's
what he would go for
but i didn't look at this d4 for a long
time d5 i think i was supposed to play
bishop e6 and knight d6
i think it's slightly more accurate that
way white cannot play this queen after
idea because here he has queen f3
and black is slightly worse but
fortunately it's very solid i i don't
remember any analysis here
i me i'm not sure if i could taken pawn
d4 but here
which movement
like here like computer would give a
more accurate move yeah
like they say bishop e6 is ws but maybe
this is a v1
and it's very dangerous
this was not very bad this is real the
computer the computer not f5 well so why
did why did the computer get bishop e6
as dubious data 5 here was the
computer's top choice ah bishop f8
knight before yeah dennis boros
mentioned queen app sixth year after the
game yes
but
but like i don't remember anything okay
gf6 that looks okay for black but with
the engine
bishop e7 maybe it's supposed to still
be okay just crazy yeah the engine just
gives crazy lines it's like
20 years ago no one would ever play like
this with white
but now the computer gives heroes then
it's definitely playable
so that's why
i decided to play bishop e6
and just a slightly worse position but
fortunately it held like here
i like knight e8 take stakes and then i
reroute my knight to the g7
um
and uh here maxim can find a way to
break through
uh rook a8 yeah and i think this is very
accurate what i did queen f6 queen d8
yeah and once the queens are traded
black is fine the point is that after f4
uh
f4 those turning but leads nowhere after
bishop d7
f5 f6
r7 g5
so after that queens were traded i think
black's position is very safe but
obviously the opening didn't go
the best for me but it's
i know we'll see what happens all right
well good luck in the last game oh yeah
it seems like you want me to predict
something
yeah yeah that's true uh linear is very
solid with black uh let's see if you
play fifa
wesley does it uh sorry just last quick
question i'll let you go and prepare for
your last round game does it affect you
your individual score versus mvl as we
we did a head to head yeah and we were
rather surprised that he's taken you
down what's the score
four four zero with 16 cross with a lot
a lot a lot of draws but you never
does that go through your head
for a big game like today's game yeah
maxim it's no secret maximum has always
been my kryptonite i
think partly the reason is because he
plays very dynamic openings with black
he plays the nightdorf and the grunfeld
openings which i tend to be
uncomfortable against
and he knows them very well
and
with white he plays for principal this
e4 somehow his style is just very
unpleasant for me so it's it's no secret
uh so i really want to to beat him once
exactly
all right well thank you very much and
good luck for the last round tomorrow
wesley well thank you
big big big result i got a that draw was
just so huge for the standings not only
in the sink field cup but for the grand
chest store and it feels like wesley all
but clint i think wesley did what he had
to do he needed a solid result not for
the tournament itself but the grand
chester thinking on the big picture
maurice what do you have for us in the
remaining games well i just want to
first point out this position yeah nice
that's king versus king
and let's go to
uh this position
not a single piece
has been traded not a single piece trade
it off few straggly pawns yes three of
them but not a single piece it's move 21
and one side jeffrey's under 30 minutes
chakra at 38
and it's just pure chaos on the board
this one who knows what's going to
happen it's still within bounds it's a
lot of action we can analyze some
variations but before we do any of that
i'd like to point out another game with
a lot of content a couple of pieces
traded here but both players under 30
minutes with 24 moves to go
24 moves
anything is going to happen in this game
i mean just anything is going to happen
we're going to have to hold our breaths
here this one
fabi finally moved he got this rook f2
idea with rook a4 hitting the bishop and
fabi is hoping that he can get an end
game upon up but this pawn is not going
to be going anywhere so a lot of
liquidation in this game very critically
this one with sam and lanier sam has
played a great move rook f rook a to c8
he's hitting this bishop
he's hitting this pawn on g2
and most importantly he's
forcing lanier to burn some clock
or at least lanier is doing it himself
we know that's what he does
16 minutes to make 21 moves
it
it gets worse and worse that's a lot of
money just keeps everything he's like
he's just completely frozen
for minutes on end and just letting his
clock time tick and tick
i mean he's down to so little time he's
fortunate the queens are off the board
how well he traded them anyway but still
there's a lot of pieces still like it
can we go back a couple of months on
this one
i thought the bishop was somewhere
useful why is it on c5 it was on e3 we
will just pick up the action that the
players had traded queens on d6 we saw
the move bishop e4 both of us wanted to
land a piece on g5 we were just not sure
which piece was going to get there no
said linear i want to tickle the bishop
don't
take the pawn on g2 that would have been
uh dreadful as once the bishop leaves
there is rook takes f6 and on deer you
can't
capture the rook so so sam said no
problem i'll just pull my bishop back
and lanier said well i want to play rook
takes f6
sam said i see that i want to play rook
takes c5 and that was how the bishop got
to c5
and this position is caused once again
another long thing i'm just not very
happy with that bishop on the a3f8
diagram i'm not happy either i don't
like them of bishops no i i thought
something had to go to g5 and by the way
this knight is ready to dance and prance
and it on a good day it might come
especially if you could chase this
bishop into some kind of like you know
go away
even a move like bishop g5 starts i
start thinking right is that it's a bit
uncomfortable i know that you have rook
d7 on top that have to be really
terrible
double attacking but you understand that
in the future if this bishop's not on
this correct diagonal yeah bishop g5 is
pretty annoying oh no question about it
we're going to let linear think in this
position good idea we want to take a
break before they get into time trouble
and i have the feeling that lanier is
going to get there very quickly this is
where we stand right now the results so
far a crucial draw between mvl and
wesley saw that has all but clinched the
grand chess tour for the american player
and clinched second place for the grand
chess tour for by sherlock we don't
think those results can really change so
there's some very
voodoo-like magic that might happen but
we don't see it we'll be right back with
the first time pressure off round eight
of the sinkhole cup
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round eight of the sing
field cup we already have a result today
a big one as maxima sharla grav and
wesley so split the point
we think this
makes sure that wesley wins the
granchester we haven't found a
mathematical refutation to that line but
that also guarantees nvl second place on
the tour but plenty to play for and the
singfield cup let's take a look where we
stand in today's round okay well let's
pick up the action in the game between
linear and sam lanier comes into
this round tied for first and we left it
more or less around this position we
just saw the move knight d2 don't take
on g2 the bishop dropped back bishop
went to c5 rook c8 and after the move
rook d7 sam said just a second can i
steal a pawn bishop takes g2 linear said
yes you can and we can get into this
bishops of opposite color position
and after the move knight f5 bishop d5
came quickly by lanier time trouble is a
big
factor white's a down upon but he's got
some good
squares for his pieces i want to say the
move knight e4 on tap for lanier we keep
an eye on this all-important match up as
we go around the horn and uh
your student
i want to say darish
as an advantage against richard that as
more and more pieces are getting traded
i just kind of feel the advantage is
slowly ebbing away
and that more of a balanced position is
being reached than an advantage for
either player we just saw the move
bishop takes c3 i'm expecting rook takes
c3
yeah very quickly play remember both
players into a bit of time trouble not
quite there yet but again the clock is
clock is a factor in this game exactly
now i'm i think you want to play queen
c7 to prepare the move castles and rook
g8 again i see this as a three result
game although i would have a slight
preference for white exactly at this
moment continuing a huge game a very
very important game going on between
fabi and peter but thanks to the bishops
of opposite colors we
kind of think that well peter should be
drawing but he's still on the back foot
it's not a pure equality yet
for peter no although
in this particular position i do imagine
that if you mishandle it with white
the d-pawn is not completely trivial
trivial to stop right i was thinking
that after uh the move bishop to d6
thinking king e6 first oh funnily enough
i was thinking
similar
hit this bishop if i could get the
bishop to move
then i would trade right now so f4
probably just saying oops sorry
oh geez where do i put it
all the way back to g3 thank you for
that uh after trades then i could go
after because
when the rook was on a5 you could tickle
my rook but now i have to move bishop
here and i just feel like draw is
inevitable if i get to play rook takes
a2 uh lastly the game with all the
pieces on the board uh king versus king
in one position
and uh not a single piece traded three
pawns have been traded oh i take it back
it looks like a pair of rooks that's off
the board just i think the rooks were on
the board when we said that yeah
and this is the current position
um
first impression pretty unpleasant for
black i don't like the offside queen on
a5 i understand you want to return it to
c7 as soon as possible although that
will have some problems with the pawn on
a6
i don't know how big the edge for white
is but i think it's white's edge yeah i
mean the question for me is this move
knight c6 now i
i don't think you 96 played by the way
yeah i was about to say i don't think
you can
do the old double attack scenario
because there is this more queen
f3 and the desired hold on queen f3 i
have another double attack i have 95
right
knight e5
just a second where is my queen going
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
hmm
uh
excuse me
no that loses
jeffrey
blunder something excuse me
did jeffrey brown we we were on the
position with knight c6 well actually at
the end at the end of this queen c7
you're not hitting my bishop this is
kind of important because i have d8
recovering
i can just defend against the mate
threat maybe another way with g2 g3 even
though even here queen takes c6 stroke
d8 should i move my king
rook takes b
bishop takes h3 now that is one pawn for
the
exchange but
very very direct threat and it's not one
part i'm worried about i think you have
to play f3
but that straight up runs into queen d6
and that i think is game right
i would not want to defend that position
whatsoever after queen takes g3 that
looks
mighty good compensation you can you
can't complain
right
well we'll go back here to maybe this
moment could i have no i can't excuse me
i cannot get on my horse and try to
uh i'm walking into a bishop c4
um
[Music]
i'm having issues uh
you had another suggestion instead of
uh i mean the only other move that
doesn't
get mated is f4 but
f
maybe
maybe f3
no i gets made it though because you got
queen h2 and bishop c4 again picks up
some material yeah yeah oh yeah it
definitely
even if it's not uh
mate you've got uh this bishop c4 as
well as uh bishop g3
uh
you are winning material and we're going
straight into it rook takes c6
bishop c6 squeeze yeah
expected
and there it is and the question has
been asked we didn't find a suitable
answer to this maurice is this good for
shock
not at all oh what not at all there is a
refutation
to this move
it has to be f2 for f4 well you were
about to get that please
well the deal is the deal is
uh you weakened your position by
stopping
the check on age two so ryan is gonna
hint and say you don't have to defend
mate by pushing your pawns
that was our hint yeah okay we can move
our queen
and get ready to move our
where do i put this queen though queen
e2 yes
queen d2 makes a lot of sense
c4 chat yeah it still gets made can we
can show this line right queen d2
queen h2 king f1
we're running but we're not very far
c4 chuck
king e1 queen g1 is mate
same thing if you play knight e2
king queen h1 is made because you don't
have any squares right and quick jeffrey
played pretty quickly on f4 which is
what we were considering but not when
maurice was telling us let's sort of
find maurice's move first he did play f4
uh queen
is that queen right
yeah we we our refugee movement was
green f3 but we were without water
knight e5 i think this is pretty
straightforward um unless i'm missing
some marvelous
tactic
with uh in this
moment i don't see it no okay his f4 is
turns out is also good all right
queen c2
side steps
because you have d2 for the because the
king can run and knight takes f4 on the
board this is getting a bit wild but
queen d2 played very quickly by jeffrey
saying
i saw all of this i do not care about
your
initiative i do not care about this
night landing somewhere i would care if
the night lands somewhere very very very
very i would be very afraid of this
knight moving somewhere exactly i don't
know where do i put this knight d4 no 95
is too much right well first of all what
about just moving the knight and saying
he wants to play queen d8
oh excuse me yeah he wants to trade the
queens remember
what's up on exchange if i trade queens
that's the end of the game that's too
much extra material so this needs to
land on the file i assume knight
by the way okay so queen takes it does
threaten queen takes g2 right mate yeah
so you're gonna have to take and i can
but you are down the exchange i don't
think this is enough okay so queen d2
knight
knight takes h3 no the problem knight
takes h3 is that you open the defense of
the queen to the h2 square
just a second let me just put this on
the board for just a moment
because i i
i
was
in the immortal words of nobody believes
you
no i don't
try it i mean maurice my yellow doesn't
be like yes of course this works but i
would never see it exactly um night
night
can i play knight d3
where's the
where's the king go
knight david three yeah because if you
take on d3 and i go queen h2 you have to
stay on dark squares because if you go
king f1 i walk into bishop c walk at the
bishop c4 what's the material a tactic
that we've seen before okay no you can't
but here you've got at least a perp
because i can never
cross into e2 or f1 right right i've got
at least a perp and maybe i've got
something
else going on here i wouldn't be that
surprised there's not a lot of defenders
around
the king
you guys worked it all out that's why
they pay you the big bucks
there you go there you go everything you
said was accurate queen number two was a
mistake
queen f3 was better
and uh quick four was not the best move
queen c2 was better and he played both
quickly queen f3 here no more no more 95
very important very clever
nice yeah he just he played very fast
and he must have overlooked this knight
d3 move and now if shakira finds it then
he gets at least a draw well he had a
real chance to win the jeffrey
and he just made his last two moves very
quickly right and now
knight d3
is a monster move and by the way this is
the crazy thing about my pick
shack riar to win the tournament
is he has been firing and sometimes he
shoots himself like yesterday against
fabiano he just collapsed told position
that maybe he was even better uh at the
at a certain moment and you know and
then he comes up with this game like
against richard and then today if he
finds knight d3 let's leave
up to finding knight this is his best
bet in the position but i want to jump
to dominguez shanklin because what on
earth just happened here okay when we
left it we saw the move bishop d5
dropped in on d4 okay that's a pretty
direct threat by the way rook takes c2
and he didn't care 94 inviting rook
takes you to chuck king b1 was played i
have a threat on the f6 bishop
that's very very clear maybe 96 maybe
some issues
well but wait a minute okay first of all
it's two pawns it's two pawns how how
big are the threats well knight f6 is
really resigning immediately okay so uh
if we move just uh just to put a move on
the board
get the bishop out of
dodge right right
it's two pawns uh
show me uh is it rook g4 what is it it's
a knight
6
96 okay again
just
whoa whoa whoa there's also a mate on
the back rank
here how do you execute this you go d2
or rook e2 right i'm just asking myself
exactly the same questions how do i do
that
rook d2 or rookie two or just
because all i'm really doing in those
cases are provoking a3 and why why why
why did i do it so let me just ask the
more direct question and if i take take
knight takes f7
i am still down two pawns
the question is if i have a real threat
coming up
right
so
do your worst
nightmare no no no it takes e5 then and
then bishop e4 right
yes yeah so i think you have to be a
little careful on the light squares it
might even be beneficial not to do
anything i'm not really sure right
exactly how do i throw it
ridiculous i know but it gets
it does invite a rook f8 checkmate at
one moment like you go here and you go
here and you go oh i'm so very clever
i'm going to take your apon and
maybe not so clever okay um
weird things going on in this game and
weird things going on in the shack
jeffrey
game what game has caught your eye uh
maurice
uh it's those games i brought in what
shaq carragher is going to do in this
moment right now as his knight is
hanging i get the feeling that shakur is
not playing for a draw
and after he sacked on c6 i think he was
unaware that he was lost right right
rook c6 queen c7 i think or less than
like at the tempo yeah like i'm doing
some stuff
and uh if
if quincy two had landed on the board
clearly his calculation was was off
right right right right right right
squeezes on the board he's in big
trouble
he's you mean instead of quindy to queen
c2 yes so we thought queen f3 right i'm
talking about this moment
not f4 not
f4 sorry
just play queen c2 right now get your
queen out of dodge this attack goes
nowhere it looks scary but you're just
marching the king over to the other side
and you're not going to get hit queen
check here just king d2 kings goes to c1
all mine squares are covered nope no
attack to hurt anywhere so and this g2
pawn is never hanging because of the
bishop on c6 so queen c2 by jeffrey if
he had found that he saves the entire
attack you can't just take this piece
because thank you very much check and we
pick off your bishop on b8 that's just a
trade and your attack is dead so
really straightforward in this moment
the queen c2 move would have just shut
things down he was afraid to play queen
f3 of course because of knight here but
his bishop guards this this is not
really a threat queen c6 is not really a
threat that's the problem rook d-8 picks
up a piece so that's not really it's
right this is your only threat what are
the different ways to guard it he played
the most committal of all the moves
giving away this pawn
granted even here he has queen f3 and
that would have been very strong so two
moves in a row
he got a chance to essentially win the
game
and jeffrey missed both
that's you can't do that you just can't
do that and now with queen d2 on the
board knight d3
shuts out the king from running anywhere
this knight lungs and d3 and you're
you're just not going anywhere what a
what a knight and this check shows up on
your doorstep with too much power with
this knight helping to fight as well the
bishop could go to c4 and guard that
piece this is just too dangerous he
would have to bail out in the line that
you guys talked about with his check
here as he cannot go to f1 because of
bishop c4 and go here and keep going
back and then we get a very fancy draw
but a great opportunity for jeffrey he's
going to come in here like what i was i
was doing that well
just gave gave the game away in a couple
of moves
missed opportunities for jeffrey um
you know he's coming into this event as
the youngest player he's getting his
opportunities to cro to duel with the
best in the world and so it's really
really nice but in some ways jeffrey is
making too many key mistakes at critical
moments like right here
like he did with mdl he's dropping half
points here and there against mvl i know
what you mean h5 takes g4 that
yeah g6 just what he wanted to do play
even for three results at that point
you're not even playing just a draw
against direct
that bishop d4 could have saved the game
right that was another half point that
he could have had wow and what a save
that would have been that would have
been derek might have been you know like
on suicide watch after that game because
it wasn't a remarkable effort by jeffrey
to save the game but just crew in key
moments crucial moments he's just not
realizing
um his opportunities by the way uh in
the game of fabiano uh fabi
is bless his heart he's trying to get
that exact set up he's hoping
that uh rook takes a2 will land on the
board so he could play bishop d4 check
and one one day
but
there's not going to be very much
material on the board by the time that
rook lands uh
uh with aggression against the g7 pawn
i'm thinking that you know you could
even maybe just play king f5 and draw
but by the way you played king e5
i think this is a bit more technical
exactly why allow the bishop to d4 i
agree
and you know what the best way of making
a draw is you play for a win you're
starting to threatening d4 d3 the pawn's
not going anywhere but let's make some
pretense right and that forces your
opponent to say well hold on let's just
draw let's let's uh let's make a
repetition
um
actually a nice game but what might have
been with rook a4
holy cow that would have been great rook
a4 rook h4 we died across the board we
got to go to the dominguez game
absolutely what uh crazy things bishop
okay okay bishop d8 makes sense the
bishop gets out of the attack of the
knight i don't particularly like the
fact that he can get hit by 96 knight f7
but i'm sure shanklin calculated
something here i would i would put it on
h
i thought that was automatic but bishop
d8 and
very anxious to win his pa pawn back was
uh
linear bishop takes f7 check immediately
if you take on f7 then rook takes the
eight
and i think this could lead into real
problems
quite possibly although i see nothing
check i think we're being too fancy just
rick takes d4
thank you uh the
the rook is depending upon the knight
for its protection
rook takes
that's all she wrote and that's all she
wrote
you have to go in
what happened
now if you take on d4 i take back
you take my rook
but
importantly i take your bishop at the
end
which is why lanier
withdrew his bishop
and the position in the game after king
h8 we have seen the move bishop d5
that does eliminate the threat of rook
takes on d4
but
uh and is now also introduces a very
very nasty but that bishop could have
gone elsewhere
but where could it go h5 for example
stopping rookie 2
and with the same maintaining the same
threat
now i
think i understand why sam put his
bishop on d8 was he
prepping the move rook c7 it could be
rookies i mean i can take on g7 still
but it's still not so clear when you
eliminate so many pieces exactly so rook
takes g7 but let's see the game position
because by the way
time the times of the players eight
minutes 19 seconds for linear dominguez
and 21 minutes for sam shanklin still
quite a bit very happy rookie too
yeah threatens checkmate he asks a
question i assume a3 in this position
right by the way i like that move just
getting out of ideas of what it takes
before let's eliminate that stuff
and we anticipate a three three looks
like an automatic to me right just to
give the king lift uh so we don't get
made checkmated on the back and this is
where for me lanier goes
completely until impractical decision
you know a3 just make the move think
about it later you will have some hard
decisions coming up save your time for
those hard decisions this new one says a
three a four four
no it's not the moment to do it you
could you can do that when you have an
extra hour on your clock but right now
you have seven minutes less than that
you have less than seven minutes you've
already spent a minute 30 on this one
just make a move a3 is a good move it's
a good move it may not be the most
perfect move more importantly than being
a good move it's not a bad move okay
that's what you need to blender you
don't blunder anything you cover from
checkmate stop thinking make the move
right
a3 and maurice over to you please
we've seen a lot of trades in the game
between darius and richard report uh
this one is down to queen versus a queen
and two rooks versus queen and two rooks
major peace end game usually it's all
about king safety well this rook has
replaced this pawn on the g line and
he's like you're not coming to get me
and how do you break through by making
any advances whatsoever a very difficult
position to win or even make progress as
white as black as all the business
squares covered and you're going to need
more and this game has ended in a draw
we expected that we knew that was coming
so d5 and e5 uh
not looking like it's going to happen
before it just looks very very difficult
to win this game
but
nine minutes on the clock to make 15
moves you're gonna need to make some
moves and something's gonna have to
happen for darius we'll see if he can
keep pace and not
cause any issues on the clock that'll
cause him to blunder all right we'll
keep an eye on the clocks in a number of
games and finally the jeffrey game and i
left it
knight d3 was found by shakira mamadorf
we expect
that will lead to a draw do we have any
alternatives for white here i'm looking
at that queen h2 and i'm looking at the
exits i'm saying okay
good game good game
not interested in seeing
black land a bishop on c4 either i'm not
even up that much material no it's like
an exchange for a pawn it's really not
that much and i think i think it's time
to bail definitely so we are expecting
the perpetual check and then just to
make sure that there's nothing more
right bishop g3 let's have a look see
king of three
now if we had our pawn brilliantly
located on the g4 square g5 square we
could play g4 checkmate and that's where
the pawn belongs right on g5 so that
when this happens you have it
uh
no nobody thinks that we have the time
to play such a move this bishop is ready
to retreat which by the way not only
when it retreats does it trap the queen
it gives black no no no and by the way
g2 is defended
so so i could just go no but it doesn't
matter bishop g3 you still have to go to
f3 right yes i do i do
okay so this is the draw that we are
expecting
why don't we see that line with g5
okay okay
check
check
king f3 g5
there is no threat right uh bishop goes
and g4 check and this bishop does a
great job at protecting the spawn and i
think that's it
so bishop c4 is a threat between queen's
hanging queen's trapped crazy isn't that
crazy
that's a kind of a funny variation
but that's it that's it that is game
over well queen h1 obviously queen h1
queen g3
makes me wonder who i'm playing right
[Laughter]
now
oops
oops oops oops that's why we're taking
the perpetual check everybody i think
there's no choice i really don't think
so the king is so weak on g1 right
and he's done it queen takes d3 smart
man no choice for shock
jeffrey didn't intuit that he was ahead
or he missed knight d3 because he
thought a long time relatively long time
after 93 and i think if you're expecting
the move to come down you kind of
realize well wait this is just a draw
exactly and once again the desired king
e2 walks into bishop c4 a move that
we've seen in a number of variations and
shaq isn't wasting time we're getting
out of here we have a repetition
maybe not
the
best played game but well it it had his
moments it was kind of it had its
entertaining 15 minutes
right yeah right okay uh let's go back
to the game of lenny oh we i'm sure
we're going to see a handshake it's
three or four times by the way it's
enough times that chris bird is going to
come around and force the draw and there
we go handshake between jeffrey and
shakira let's just jump to the linear
reward specifically i want to see why he
hasn't moved he hasn't moved if he fell
asleep on the board if you forgot he has
a clock and he had eight minutes at this
exact moment right
when when
when
shanklin played rookie two dominguez had
eight minutes on his clock he's finally
made a move he has two minutes 11.
how does he do this
six minutes playing rook g2 g1
when a3 was a decent move
and that is just
impractical yeah that is just so wrong
same move faster
right if you wanted to play rook g1 do
it right away if you want to play a3 do
it right away but to say six 75 percent
of his time on this out of all moves
right and he's going to need that time
down the line uh absolutely absolutely
we do have a special guest in studio
getting set up
might as we do have three draws out of
the five games thus far today this game
is crazy the other game that's still
going on is the game
of richard
and derek not much is happening so let's
just go to our guest at studio
maurice we do have fabiana caruana after
a draw against peter svidler fabia i
just have a couple of quick questions
for you starting with your mindset
coming into this game given that you
were half a point out of first
yeah i wanted to win um
i thought that uh
i could put pressure with white and and
i even had an idea to play this in this
line i was trying to play it in previous
games in the tournament but i didn't
manage
um
[Music]
and i think he was kind of surprised so
i got a good good position um
i was surprised he went for
what was a very statically
i mean a position where basically he's
just trying to hold
but he has of course the drawing margin
is very high i mean he can
um
instead of cd4
no no
forward
after
after i canceled he can play like
brigade8 c4 there's various various
moves uh
cd4 is is admitting that he's um trying
to
to simplify as much because of course
the obstacle bishops and the open
position makes it
sort of draws but if i get a grip if i
get bishop d4 f3 rookie one then he
really suffers
maybe queen before it was bad maybe
queen
queen b3 was a better move i was
actually regretting
that i played queen before queen b3
avoids the bishop before stuff because
my bishop on e3 is defended so there's
always f3
this doesn't work out
because you play queen b4 and then he
played bishop to e4
and he decided to take on b6 well i i
thought a long time the first thing is
that okay f3 doesn't work because of
bishop f3 um
and rook fe1 which looks like it
prepares f3
he suddenly has queen h5
and then i'm in serious danger actually
because f3 rook f3 and
uh no not rook fd1 um work for e1 okay
one sorry to prepare f3 because if i get
f3 i think i'm just
uh crushing it yeah yeah
uh but queen h5 so queen g4 is a threat
queen g6 is also a threat um and if f3
rook takes f3 and if i take i get mated
so this was unfortunate
um
and so i spend most of my time
trying to figure out
how to not play queen takes v6
and i thought mainly about queen d2
which is
not really the ideal move but it does
prepare f3
um
okay rook a3 and i
it's very very complicated and i
couldn't quite see how to proceed here
um
so i mean there's a lot of
a lot of messy lines uh
but i just didn't see my next move you
know i have f3 i have bishop d4
um
but he has like queen h5 he gets all
this incredible activity with the
sacrifices on f3 and rook d3 coming
um and queen takes b6 i had a feeling
it's going to be a draw but i hope that
there might be some way to put pressure
in that game but i couldn't um it's
either way if we may interrupt first
momentarily it looks like
dominguez has blundered
uh oh and maybe lost in this position he
played the move bishop to e6 and the
rook takes e4 bishop takes and rook to
f4 seems to be quite advantageous one
second we don't we don't have you on
there we go if you could repeat the
variation sorry uh
bishop e6 can be bit by takes takes and
rook to f4
and
uh this the threat on this bishop
obviously this doesn't do anything
because of this rook taking and there is
no perpet as your rook is in trouble you
can't touch this bishop so bishop to e6
it looks as though rook takes e4 bishop
takes and rook moves your bishop could
drop back and then he could shut
everything down with g6 black is up a
pawn this one doesn't look long for the
world either so looks like lanier may be
in big trouble that would shake up the
entire standings
of course
let's get back to fabi finishing your
point no my game's not interesting let's
let's do that
so so your game your game ended in a in
a draw now uh you must be
not too thrilled with seeing the draw or
maybe you are happy seeing the draw
happen between maxima and wesley because
you're still only half a point out of
first
i kind of expected a draw in that game
um
so i i mean i'm a bit disappointed i
couldn't
do more in this game couldn't put more
pressure on him i i felt like there
should have been a way to be more
accurate
um
but
you know i i like i don't think i miss
anything
um crushing you know it's not like i had
a winning position or anything i had a
bit of an advantage and i didn't make
the most of it um and as for
what happened in maximus wesley i
i really don't see why
that affects me too much
i mean
well you'd have to win tomorrow and hope
that
maxine draws right in order to tie for
first yeah i mean for me it was the most
important was to
was to win today
um it's a
you know i'm playing richard in the last
round
um he's a very fighting player so that
makes all results possible i don't think
he's um
going to be searching for
a quick draw or anything i think he's
going to fight um
and that's also not a bad thing for me
potentially so so we'll see
all right well good luck tomorrow thank
you thank you fabi indeed uh good luck
tomorrow as we have uh three draws
in this penultimate round with two games
remaining and much to our surprise after
the move night and there we have it uh
three straws as we can see but let's
take a look at your board
uh yasser as there was a blunder by
dominguez but it was not exploited which
was a big surprise big surprise to us
you're sitting here in this position uh
lanier played the move bishop
e6 and as pointed out
very very simple stuff here takes takes
give me the bishop
and when the bishop retreats where did
we reach or move the bishop anywhere
right it didn't matter you played g6 you
stopped and you played g6 and you're
you're golden yeah you're gonna lose
i don't think black's necessarily
winning but uh
forever absolutely plus
uh but what we saw instead strangely
enough was the move knight d4 bishop
back to east that's at least one
repetition sam has
stopped he has stopped he has a chance
to go knight f5 again right of course
lanier doesn't need to repeat because of
the clock times now let's get into sam's
head a little bit now wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute you know you got
two minutes on the clock
i think the position's super double
edged
why couldn't it still happen why
shouldn't i i press why don't i play g6
why don't i
consider my options and i think sam's
maki especially as he has the time to do
so
uh he's taking a deeper
calculation into the position also it
was a good time to take a calculation of
before
94
i'll grant you that no question about it
13 minutes for sam shanklin still by the
way maybe there was one trick we didn't
actually get a chance to look at it it
was bishop e6 rook takes e4 bishop takes
f5 rook f4 maybe it was this move that
dissuaded him uh
because
wait a minute what am i i'm doing it
this way right i think you have i don't
really know what you want to do i want
to make it perpetual ah
somehow
uh but i'm not i'm not succeeding even
rookie chain at this point right it's
just sufficient well looks weird it
looks weird but it looks like it holds
on for sam we do have a guest with us
jeffrey chong drew his game against
shakur and mahmoud yarov let's have that
interview with maurice ashley
jeffrey we're in time pressure in
another game so we don't have much time
but you did have an opportunity here
two opportunities in fact queen c2 and
the way you played f4 knight takes and
queen f3 looks like it would have been
advantageous for you when you played
here queen d2 did you think that i just
had to shut this position down or just
uh didn't see his knight d3 uh yeah i
completely blundered knight d3
i definitely thought
i was much better after queen d2 but
yeah 93 was kind of a cold shower for me
there's been some half points you've
missed in this tournament you could have
drawn against dariush with a bishop d4
move now this one
got to be a little bit under the skin
seeing that there's a couple of moments
you could have had a much better score
yeah that's true after i would say i was
very lucky to uh to survive against
shrinkling but yeah as you mentioned
maybe these uh the game against schwertz
maybe
wesley against wesley could have done
better
but uh yeah i mean it's part of the
tournament yeah it is what it is do you
feel like you're getting a little bit
closer take some lessons from this game
to prepare you to be stronger for the
future
oh for sure yeah coming here to play uh
36 games i guess against these guys is
just
huge for uh for my chess development so
yeah the more games i get the more i
learn
all right well good luck tomorrow thanks
very very quick question for you jeffrey
because we're almost out of time
you're feeling you've played 2 800 grand
masters you played 27 under grand
masters what's the big difference
between those two weight divisions
yeah i don't know it's hard to say um
i would say that the when i play this
event
it feels like you know there isn't too
big of a gap i mean we're all human
we're all making mistakes so
yeah it's very hard to say
okay thank you and good luck tomorrow
and we have the uh it's such an
important game we have to just jump
right back into it knight f5 played
again by sam an invitation an invitation
to repeat but it could be possible
rook takes e4 that linear looks at the
position and thinks wait a second why
didn't he take on e4 last time i noticed
and he might have noticed he might
change his move not because he doesn't
want to draw but because he notices that
bishop e6 is not good exactly and i'm
sure he calculated that he probably you
know one of those you put the piece on
the screen you go
oh no what if you just do it it's what
happens it's what happened to lanier
against peter svidler he
drops the queen on b3 and realizes
whoops b5 is winning right
maybe oops he gets a second chance here
right and
since we know
that bishop e6 rook takes e4 advantage
black
i
stopped it again second chance again a
second chance incredibly
he could take on e4
is it that we're missing rookie for
bishop f5 what is it for the question i
think is what are they what is sam what
is this and lanier no there's no
question rookie four they probably think
that the
why can't i play rook takes g7 rook the
h7 rook f takes f5 that's the problem
and kind of kind of miraculously after
rook takes h17 g8 rook dg7 king f8 rook
d7 you have bishop f6 and the bishop
actually controls both squares
it's kind of amazing
that you're delivering checkmate on
either h8 or d8 and you're
not let me correct you dear sir there is
nothing and maybe that's the move that
they're missing sometimes maybe it looks
like it's a draw
and they don't see bishop f6 right you i
mean i have to say that
many games multiple games double
blindness double blindness
yes he's repeated he does man this is
gonna be a moment the draw is a foot
and sam could have completely changed
the tournament and that's sure
i'm going to bet bishop f6 is the movie
missed yeah and for linnear by the way i
mean you know he came into the game with
white
tied for first he says i'm going to play
the move bishop d5 and i'm going to
claim a draw and sam says that's shake
hands
yeah yeah you don't actually need
arbiter permission
and that's it
a draw between linear dominguez and sam
shanklin from
a winning position
is it
that's what that's what the engine says
i'm not going to argue with the engine
yeah
i've learned my lesson on that one if
it's not winning you're up upon right
queen and you're about to win a second
pawn and this is what we're trying to
figure out the bishop has to move
yeah it's just hanging this again this
was uh what we're trying to figure out
is why
sam didn't just go for this position
because the move rook g7 doesn't work
we're thinking that the bishop moves you
can play g6 where it's gold
rook f2 isn't it
dropping no we know why we know why he
didn't play this line he missed it
it's like you almost want the players to
go into the confessional booth and say
uh you know i think i might have missed
something there i hope i get sam because
i really want to know what the
calculation miss
was
we have one game remaining and the
players are
actually i think discussing this very
final position the one game remaining is
with richard rapport
uh game against derrick uh move my man
move what i want
whenever we come to uh
uh
schwartz's game i want to ask what's the
time 50 seconds for dario sphere seven
minutes for richard report eleven
twenty
twelve twelve moves
and he's sitting there calmly not
jumping up and down in his chair like
one alejandro ramirez is right now like
come on dude move
thank you anything that move is great do
it any joy whatever you're thinking put
your hand on it and do it right this is
exactly a situation that richard would
hope for and he finally has played a
move queen for did you really need to
think for that long or for queen f4 wow
it's kind of a remarkable move too
actually what is this move oh he wants
to go to c7 and take her pawns yay yay
okay i'm proud same move better the same
move faster was better
queen f4
you know when i'm in those situations
where i'm starting to get a little bit
antsy you know i start looking at really
forcing variations first so i mean the
move that might have had my attention
and maybe
he was really trying to do his best to
calculate it is you know something like
where i want to bail i want to play d5 i
want you to take i don't know exactly
how you intend to take but i wanted to
um i might even take on d5 four
yeah
or if you prefer right i like taking on
d5 first because
if you think with the pawn now i take
with the queen which is exactly why i
wanted to play i wanted to ruin black's
pawn structure with the move d5 so i
think you have to take with the rook
right then i take back
now my rook is hanging on d1 so i have
to be a little bit careful i was kind of
wondering
how did you
like the two rooks i wouldn't even be
worried about that i haven't ruined your
structure so i don't even want to get
into this so rook takes politics
i was wondering if you can play
something like rook c1
because c1 i see the rook on g6 and i'm
wondering if i can just well it's one
dimensional right yeah i mean all you've
got is threats against g2 so long as i
keep those guys covered this rook
or rook c8 even sometimes right right
and i can uh i can start thinking yeah i
can
has launched
richard into the tank they are playing
so
slowly well the only thing i can imagine
that richard is considering
other than you know some kind of normal
moves is something like king
h8 in order to
you're trying to get into the mind of
richard right
not an easy move to play
yeah well in that case i might have
played rook g8 but as we keep an a
careful watchful eye on this game we
have another guest in studio alejandro
yeah sam shanklin with maurice ashley
and indeed that that game he's made a
move that richard and we're going to
have to get to that
five the seconds are ticking oh a big
time decision
sam's apologies there's just he's got
less than
46 he's got 30 seconds left it is and
it's got to make a move so we can't jump
away just yet this kind of time pressure
stop thinking i make a move sam when you
see something like this do you feel any
willies or who you're thinking what
what's this guy doing taking so much
time he's got 10 more moves to make oh
it's just part of the game i don't think
white is in any real danger here to just
if you just play a couple of normal
moves you're never going to be worse so
i don't know it seems okay to me
all right he has taken on e5 and we are
expecting to see a quick response there
sam i just because of this time pressure
just one quick moment right here we knew
uh rook takes we we know
the engine points out rook takes e4 is
winning for you did you is there
something of course i thought about it
i'm just trying to figure out what i
missed i mean rookie four is bishop five
is it rook h or no because rook h rook
f4
oh rook gg7 there's rook 8f5
oh that sets
so you missed this point i missed okay
it takes a five yeah
that's the one
and then it's gone yeah
ah that's gonna leave a mark
okay well apologies we just were curious
as to what happened you played a fine
game
defending and also coming back in the
game and had a momentary chance yeah i
mean i thought i played him pretty
convincingly at some point i was worried
i was a bit worse at the start of this
end game after bishop takes e4 maybe i
should have not exchanged queens i don't
know but i just thought i sort of
outplayed him without
a ton of trouble and then at the end i
i just missed this detail there's rook 8
takes f5 in this position examine all
checks and captures back to basics and i
had 10 minutes i could have thought it
but um
yeah i don't know i was
surprised at how easily it came to me
that black ended up better but did i
miss something before or no
yeah this was the spot all right
that's really depressing but what can
you do all right well
sorry we have to get going back to the
other game but uh yeah sure good luck
tomorrow thank you
indeed sam good luck for your final game
as we get ready to close out the sink
field cup 2021
but it's about the clock it's all about
the clock the last game remaining here
in the eighth round
it's still complicated and it really
comes down to ken black's pieces on the
king side
let's take a look rook takes d3 rook
takes d3 queen e2
let me drop in for a visit i've got the
e4 pawn i got the rook on e3 and that's
all i got because after queen e3
but 23 is just a little bit too drawish
right well indeed it's very very drawish
but did you see it good
um i think i want to play rookie 3 let
me keep those major pieces on the board
because your king's a bit weaker than
mine i have queen c5 maybe on top
fair enough where do i go where do i go
quick quick quick
my clock is ticking quick quick quick
quick quick you might have to go back to
h5 tail between your legs here right oh
yeah then why did i why did i go why did
i why did i uh trade rooks and do all of
this if i wasn't uh playing for queen
ooh
the players are taking time could i do
that could i do no no no it's ridiculous
it's completely ridiculous right
the best i've got is a draw after g3 but
do you have a draw
i'm not i'm not sure
in any case i think that's true or i
think g4 is
no i don't know i i don't think i have a
draw even after g3 and so on but
once again we have another guest in
studio alejandra
hello murray's taking away
we are with lanier dominguez who is
currently tied for second place lanier
there's a dangerous moment in the game
at the very end right here it looks like
there was a case of mutual blindness as
uh
rook takes e4 looks like it's winning
for black did you see this yeah no i
didn't see it
during the game i just found out now
that
after i thought of course bishop takes a
five rook four brook gg7 but i of course
missed that rook ff5 and then
uh
black is winning so yeah i don't know
i i felt that i was that i had
compensation of course here but yeah i
completely
missed this i was very lucky that
he missed it as well it's somewhat
strange or interesting the pattern of
taking the rook off the back rank yeah
it's probably
visually it looks uh like white is doing
well that's why we both
missed it probably
you're in a tie for second tomorrow
uh you could make a big dent in the
tournament as you're playing against
wesley
yeah it's uh of course a
crucial game so
i'll i'll try to just uh
do my best and see what happens i i have
black which is
kind of not the best but it's a
situation where you just have to play
the game and forget about the
the result
all right okay we'll let you go as we
have time pressure in another game good
luck tomorrow thank you uh just a quick
question lanier i want to bring up the
game that's going on right now it's the
game uh between derek and richard your
quick knee-jerk reaction would you
prefer to play white
or black or would you prefer to have 30
seconds
looks like white is uh
it's
very safe now because uh black's king is
a slightly more
expensive exposure d4 play
[Music]
challenge 26. i mean when your
opponent's in time trouble it's these
surprise moves rook d4 you still feel
the same way
yeah probably uh black's king is anyway
a bit exposed there okay so rook takes
d4 pawn takes d4 thank you lanier and
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
queen takes h3
i was thinking queen f3 but no queen
takes h3 on the board g3 it's not a
perpetual if you take on g3 i hide
because the e3 square is going to be the
question is what's your thoughts now
linear are you doing
i mean
it's very concrete like after ed4 i
don't know rook d4 seems possible uh
but also maybe some moves like queen b2
i think i still think that uh black is
in some
some
danger here or potentially could be
dangerous because of of the king i don't
see what black is doing concreting
concretely on on g3
wow okay ice cream thank you
guys thank you
so much you got nothing
i like that movie queen b2 a loss by
richard
and the tour is over for sure
we we put that in our graphic up at the
very start of the show win games
well we didn't put that in our graphics
we could keep the board we didn't
include that in our graphic yeah i think
we said uh we said he had to we he had
to win we know we can keep the wins et
cetera but thank you a loss on a draw by
wesley and a loss
by richard ends everything well i guess
we did kind of yeah we did it we
derivatively put it in our graph all
right a couple of choices here is it
like is is there a storm going on
outside because ice
i swear that playing hall is really well
lit
and this looks strangely dark right
remember we had a storm the other day
that was really
almost hurricane like gale going on
rook takes d4 and again lanier
said
his feeling was white's king is
perfectly safe
and that it was a question of black skin
and we've mentioned this about heavy
piece end games a queen and a rook or a
queen and two rooks it's all about king
safety and despite the fact that there's
a queen circling around white's king
on the long run this king on g7 just has
no protection
so black is the one that needs to create
some sort of counter play i imagine h5
is going to let's start with the most
obvious and is time time's a factor 47
seconds for darius 50 seconds for
richard
richardson seven moves to make why is
richard hesitating in playing the move
h5 because i take a lot of players c3
you might be getting made it yourself
that's the question about these kind of
positions
king moves out of the way of this
discover check yes and i go rogue d8
rook d8 and
um
quickly back to he's going to play f6
but you understand that after f6
over here okay but he didn't do that he
brought his queen back did richard no h5
e6
hoping to post up with maybe queen e5
with the queen on the e5
diagonal i want to say on the long
diagonal then black's king
feels a lot safer i would like to post
up with my queen on e3 as white oh sorry
maurice what how many
seconds we got 13
11.
nine
eight no
seven my heart is ticking super fast at
this point
oh my goodness queen c3 on the board and
we're expecting queen to e5
or queen f6 both which look very logical
as the diagonal is now covered that's a
surprising queen i say because i would
have wanted to be able to play rook on
g6
to d6 right so i think queen e5 would
have been my choice that was not
richard's choice he did play queen f6
and
to his credit he played that rather
quickly
and we're back to that situation ten
seconds nine counting down eight once
again will he trade no he won't he could
have offered a trade of queens
but i like three i like the right queen
absolutely e5 on top now so you have to
why didn't you play queen why didn't he
put queen e5 in that way you don't have
this move queen e3 that's an excellent
question
where they come in here but but it's
nervous right it's nervous
you see the clock ticking you have a few
moves to make they're
e5 h5 on the board you know that
richard's not going to miss a chance to
play h5 in this position the question is
if e5 is uh
e5 does why would you not only five not
only is e5 with the tempo it does stop
it doesn't he tries h4
there it is there it is big move queen
moves somewhere i don't like putting it
on f5 because it runs into rook f4 i'm
playing queen esa
right no i'm playing queen g5 i'm i'm
i'm heading into a rook ending
which i'm thinking
is that a happy ending for you i think
so i really yeah i don't think that it
would be too dreadful but
he goes for it he did go for it
you were expecting you said queen e7 all
day
well i'm proven wrong yet again
commentator's curse there seems to be
some
[Laughter]
say hello but rookie four might
know more than yeah
rook f4 does allow h4 and you can't play
rook takes h4 in that case either
because you have to worry about a queen
of three siding not not necessarily
because rook takes half seven minutes
i understood i don't know
he had two seconds left he said no why
would i ever keep risking
bail queen takes
this looks like it's headed towards the
draw either e6 or rook d7 yeah rook d7
rook takes e5 rook takes b7 a5 good
enough now that's good enough for a draw
right right and no real risk of either
player really flagging they got two more
moves to make but they don't i still see
eight seconds seven seconds six seconds
wow yes four seconds what
and he did play rook d7 with a cool two
seconds a cool two seconds on the clock
no problem by the way rook f4 h4 lost
wow
and we do have rook takes e5 sorry to
say gentlemen but i do believe this may
be our fifth draw consecutive draw for
the round a very exciting round no
questions about it but
in the end not a lot of decisive uh
moments here well they should teach the
production crew to make any graphics
regarding the percentage of
wins
exactly it was our hubris it was our
hubris this is
to suggest that we were going to keep up
an 80
win rate or a 60 win rate whatever it
was and we have it's gonna turn into a
two versus two the players will find
some repetition very very very very
quickly and this will be the fifth draw
of today's round
again an exciting eventful round but uh
not much no sparks flying today really
right the tour title is still in doubt
however for sure uh as
richard
is that true yes if wesley draws
tomorrow it's over right yes but if
wesley loses what could go wrong
if wesley loses tomorrow
i don't think it's enough
and vl would have to win
before
mvl would have to win against mahmud
yarov
right no because lanier can draw they
they could no linear can't draw if
wesley loses why's he's playing linear
oh right was that's true evie would also
have to win that's that's double whammy
that's a double whammy right there but
then richard would also have to win
against fabi
which would give a three-way tie for her
yeah that's three-way tie for a third
it's good for wesley the players can
actually cocktail then it's over a
referendum this draw does end the event
and the grandchildren draw them off the
tour we think it does it's not the sink
filled cup not the sinful cup but i
think it's it's true
if we we'd have to confirm that math but
i think wesley is the tour winner i
think so too right now
thank you and there we have that
handshake has sealed the deal it looks
like is what let's just do our math
again to make sure all right all right
wesley so
let's say worst case scenario loses to
lanier correct
now linear catches
mvl and mvl needs 13 points evil worst
case scenario for wesley needs 13 points
he beats mamadiarov all right so that's
why now it all comes down to the
rockport versus carolina game
at this moment fabi would be if fabi
scores anything and goes ahead of wesley
richard can't catch him wesley ends up
in fourth by himself wins the tour and
if rockport wins against bobby he
catches both wesley and bobby tied they
tied for a third which is good enough
seven points and seven is enough to win
yes leslie has one underground turret
yes our great congratulations wesley
repeats because he won it was a while
ago he hasn't been a winner he hasn't
done it since 2016. but
wesley so is back in town and it is
about consistency in this event really
he did
or the five events he didn't win a
classical
but he never scored worse than fourth
unless yeah no never scored worse than
force and and the number of defeats he
had was infinitesimal undefeated thus
far in this the syncfur world cup in the
rapids he was just phenomenal amazing
phenomenal how do you do that he's an
incredible defender it's so hard to beat
wesley so wow it really is right and
that's how you do the 100k
not bad not about baby he's got 100k in
the pocket i got to go say wesley it's
time for dinner where are we heading
where are we going
oh the gentlemen uh
kudos to the players they kept this to
our
edge of our seats this whole round uh we
do have one
more day the ultimate round uh tomorrow
it's the last round off the grand chess
tour we have to figure out who is going
to win the sing field cup but we have
figured out who won the entire tour
there will be no playoff on august 27th
because that's only for the gct it's not
for the singfield cup we also know
second place is maximum do we still have
a doubt without we have a doubt on third
right because favi could still
theoretically pass my med
yes yes
325 000 in prizes 10 players jockeying
in the sinkville cup a lot of players uh
a half a point could be a very
meaningful difference uh for the down
the ranks uh and they're guys see our
current current standings mvl five and a
half points well situated going into the
last round remember he is black against
mamadiaro tomorrow so still a dangerous
opponent fabiano carrana with five
points will be facing off also with
black against richard report wesley so
versus lanier dominguez that's a big one
for the sing field cup standings right
wesley he already won the tour he might
as well say hey
one shot why not risk a little bit here
right right and exactly and this is what
i was thinking the players who have
three and a half points and peter
svidler three points uh
jeffrey shack sam peter win a game that
could be a 20 000 swing depending upon
the other results of course but i'm just
saying that 325 000 in prize money uh
there's some uh very very handy
let's let's be clear let's get this
let's take a look as we see the division
of prize money here let's get the tour
score
up the tour where they stand on the tour
right now because bobby no longer
can get it second second that's gone on
the tour that's gone
but he could get second in this
tournament he could get yeah
he could even get first right so let's
just be clear fabi is at 16 he's six
points behind chakrillar right right in
order to to cast him
you need six to pass him he needs seven
if he gets he needs plus six is what
we're saying exactly so if he comes in
well if he wins the tournament then he's
guaranteed third actually i don't think
chakriar
is going to get that many points where
shakaria stands depends how he does i
guess sakurai could win as well mm-hmm
well shakira wins fabi wins five wins
the same field cop solo that's 13.
that's 13 14. what a trampoline jump
that will be for yeah bobby because by
the way i mean tabby just came in this
tournament not
well actually came into the rapid and
blitz not feeling that good about his
chances at all but
two back-to-back great results yeah even
if he didn't win either one of those
tournaments two seconds in a row that's
pretty consistent that's what you want
to see
gentlemen
we haven't talked about it so much in
the second half of the event because i
think the first half really took most of
the chances we've seen so far brilliancy
prize
i've got two candidates yeah and i don't
have that many more outside of those no
i don't either if peter had found rook
a4 today and followed it up with rook h4
that would have been sweet but here it
is the brilliancy
alejandro the brilliancy prize donated
by brian priester of key west florida
five thousand dollars he has given us to
split among the players however we see
fit that was a mistake but thank you for
the trust we have to determine how we
want to do this the brilliancy prize we
really do want to give it to something
that wowed us to that was special that
involved
you know unusual chess unusual and cool
and i have to say in the second half
it was
nice we had some good games a little
tepid compared to the first half oh yeah
the the definitely the two games that we
have in mind the linear game with queen
a1 and the fabi game where he sacrificed
even though he called it a
sham sacrifice
i was thinking that we might need a tie
break over there i thought
i thought fabby's game was a contender
the linear game i think
is definitely the and the shot shot game
was super exciting but a brilliancy wow
okay well i mean you guys are gonna have
to join us for the closing ceremony to
see how we broke
it all up we got three judges and you
know we're very impartial extremely
impartial
well maurice final thoughts of today's
round as we head towards the closing of
the 2021 tour
well it would have been nice to see
some drama going into round nine not
knowing who's going to win the tour but
congratulations to wesley so mr
consistent indeed did win a big event in
paris and show that when he needs to
stay near the top he always does that's
the way you want to get it done he
hadn't had a great result on the tour in
a while since the one he won in 2016 he
had just middle of the road results to
win again is special you know he matters
to him that he's done this twice now
great great result for him but the drama
remains in the last round for the last
day
we'll see who wins the sink field cup
itself a bunch of players want a chance
at this title you know favi desperately
wants it again mvl for sure we still got
excitement to take care of tomorrow
absolutely absolutely maurice i couldn't
agree more well join us tomorrow for the
last round of the sing philica we'll be
crowning a champion i honestly hope it's
just one champion but we still don't
know who it is
see you then good night everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you